is it here
yes hey
hi nice to see you what what's wrong you
think this is a game does this look like
a game to you
oh this right here oh you watched the
yeah i just watched off the rails
yeah we're having fun with the gatsby
let's see what's the problem yeah i'm
gonna i'm taking this away
you know this is our new building come
on yeah i'm just having fun
you know you
can't hey
[Applause]
you're right
[Music]
[Music]
just i don't trust you on that thing
[Music]
do you think this is a game
no more gatsby seriously dude you are a
menace on that thing ela stop stop
okay okay okay i promise i promise no
more on the gas can i keep it please no
man you're crazy on that thing that i
that was terrifying
ila come on
no please this is ridiculous
you're way more dangerous than that
thing that i am going to be able to get
out of the door for help okay all right
i have to say it kind of just takes over
yeah
so
if you guys missed it we did it off the
rails on wednesday that was a lot of fun
maybe a little bit too much fun and ila
came
to uh well you gotta chill you're
already destroying walls it's like i was
like you know it's my office i own this
[ __ ] right so do you want it to look
like
a kind of no but i think it's funny if
there's like damage everywhere
said crew members
you know
oh welcome everybody to after dark
today's episode is sponsored by roman
swipes wait to hear about these things
[Music]
wow
friday baby
it's friday how you feeling ela good to
see you by the way feeling good
yeah
do you or do you want to apologize for
how you were driving that thing or
you feel like i you are in the right
yeah
because you were coming at me pretty
hard it
genuinely scared me you had it coming
how's everything else going
good
excellent
um so
okay
um what is this
how's that how's that okay here this was
something that we need to talk about
this is something we need to address all
right love in the last episode people
have been noticing
that he why do you do this love you do
well let's see if there's actual well
let's see here's the actual image
of the face he always makes wow but it
does look like you're always doing blue
steel where you're kind of puckering up
like
you know talk to me baby and right
and
is that something that you know you do
or is that something that
by the way love love has been transport
his consciousness has been uploaded to
the matrix and he's
now on a bot
here let's see you love i want to see
you
all right here's me yeah so love is in
now in a bot dan
so did you know that that was something
you did where you kind of pucker up blue
steel
no kinda yes no not really because
i think there's two parts to it
i guess my mouth
i kind of pucker up it's just a habit
i don't know i just suck every all the
air out of my air my mouth
like that um
then it's the eyes
i have
four screens in front of me and a
completely dark room
which i don't think is super healthy
with your eyes definitely not
and um so i kind of just
uh don't open my eyes that much
you look good though you got that sexy
look
oh i'm going to come
dance about to come
here's all the memes about you love you
cheers to all these yeah by the way i
enjoyed the meme a lot
handsome squidward you do kind of
resemble a handsome squidward
this is you people are saying this is
what they think you think you look like
do you think you look like a sexy e-boy
yeah
yeah we've been having way too much fun
out here in the office the new office we
got all the space and everything
oh
good times
um you know it's james charles birthday
so we have a whole birthday celebration
planned for him
coming up later
um i just thought it was so special how
this guy who's kind of just been outed
as a really
i people always make fun of me because
now apparently i'm saying prolific a lot
okay
it used to be fascinating and people
shamed me out of saying fascinating now
i'm saying prolific a lot but you
describe it you just you find a better
describer of james predatorness than
prolific
let's get glam no it's accurate yeah i
mean he is accurate
i mean the guy is hitting like expert
numbers i'm desperate he's hall of fame
[ __ ] he got 2.1 million which like even
before the controversy
this is a big post for him right
so he has not lost any support
um he said hey guys just want to say
happy birthday
you know he's going heading out to chuck
e cheese later
to celebrate
with all of his with all his friends
that's where they like to go
age-appropriate hey before we get to
that though um
bring them on i have i have a special
guest on the line just bring them on
okay who's on one second
just a moment here
friday
let's go baby let's [ __ ] go
it's friday baby friday
friday memorial day weekend day five we
made it this is now memorial day weekend
officially right
not next yeah this monday
it's this money baby cheers baby cheers
baby [ __ ]
friday yeah baby
your shirt says black what's on the rest
of your shirt just i just see black
black heather
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah baby
[ __ ] yeah friday
friday baby friday
is there school
hell no school today is there work
hell no no
friday baby
baby [ __ ] yeah all right thanks gabe
take care have a great weekend
all right
cheers buddy bye
love to hear from gabe
you know you got to start off friday
with the right tone
it's friday baby
anyway james charles um
can you believe the amount of support um
and then there's also like big ass
influencers who are like happy birthday
sweetheart see you at chuck e cheese
later for the big bash
so you have brian singer's house later
wow sister snapped
this guy
who's this guy
oh he's not even big he only has 80 000
he's just on that clout pill
so
embarrassing
but anyway so
um we actually
are super excited to be celebrating his
birthday
we have some call-ins lined up we also
have
um some great videos and some good times
planned for example elo
yeah
here okay you know what a thirst trap is
on tick tock
no
i feel like i've heard that but i don't
know actually what it is okay so a
thirst trap
is when you're just trying to bait like
horny it could be like a for men or
women or you're trying to bait like
horny young people to just like
get
when people live comment like you don't
want to check my stories yeah yeah well
and then if you check and it's like them
like this like a girl in a tiny bikini
titties yeah it's a thirst trap
so i found the weirdest thirst trap ever
a dude on tick-tock
who does thirst traps with his sister
little sister
uh
okay it's a definite bra moment but it's
on tick tock so i mean how bad could it
be
baby well famous last words right
but this guy's a huge um creator
maybe it's a cultural thing you guys
tell me i don't know because he's like
he's he's italian or something or maybe
spanish
i'm trying to put it on italian 4
million well i don't know i mean
the guy that benefited out of here
you know well you see how moe and et are
like hey come on they're pretend
italians though they're not actually
italian what money tiara and italia you
got that it's a joke i think they think
they are but all right you tell me what
you think about this all right
the
title is little sister you are my life
now i love my sister but i would never
say she's my life
that's hyperbole
it's so people say that
that's fine okay
okay fair enough
there's just some strap music playing
she's like 12 bro i don't know what the
[ __ ]
what
it's so cool that's kind of weird so do
you think
so what do you think is this
kind of weird
well all the comments are like bro what
is wrong with you yeah this is wrong
but again it's on tick tock it's got
like a 8 million views this video oh my
god is this a big account oh yeah yeah i
know he's super popular he's a popular
thirst trap
person i'm gonna come uh
this is uncomfortable this is wrong
something they adding up here yeah well
here's one so americans cannot
understand he isn't from here other
countries have good relationship with
their siblings that's so i'll say that's
good
i mean good what do you mean by good
i like my sister
not trying to [ __ ] my sister
peace and love
okay but wait there's more okay okay i'm
not done painting definitely making me
feel weird though
okay okay
um where's my mouse literally can't okay
here it is so here's another one with
this sister
okay now y'all just tell me
if something ain't adding up here
okay kind of wholesome so far
[Music]
no
zach
maybe this one's not as bad
uh it's it's not as bad as that first
yeah that first one was worse very
because
then he's trying to like kiss her on the
i don't know
i never touched anyone like
that intimate with you know
but again i'm just saying maybe it's
cultural maybe this is a learning
experience for us yeah if it was just
this one i would say hey wait there's
some with his mom ela
[Music]
[Laughter]
here's the one with this mom
zach get the music out of here yeah that
is inappropriate it's underage
get out of here
so she says today's my birthday my mom
surprised me
okay
that's his mom
okay
so he's just like that with everyone so
that's my theory as this guy is at
my theory is that this guy's just
i don't know dude i don't know that's
mommy make out thing
but do you like would you touch your mom
in this way guys i mean a lot going on
there
no no i i i'm pretty close with my mom
but um but not that close but again it's
the italian swag i don't know maybe
the mommy's down though
i'm not sure but that's the only thing i
can think
of i kind of want to get a call from
someone in italy
or europe who can like give us some
perspective because i don't want to be
like right coming off as ignorant
appetite american
yeah no i mean you're right that
ram your younger sister
yeah no i
there's definitely uh a closer intimacy
in some cultures but that that
i've never seen anything like that
yeah
anal sex
thank you rudy
i don't know i feel like people could
say i'm being i don't know but if
somebody on if somebody on the
if somebody wants to call in with some
perspective especially from italy i'd
love to hear it
but there is actually uh someone in
america who this has who does do this
really so it's not unprecedented here so
maybe this could help give us some
perspective
here
this is even worse than kissing
so this is chris from prank invasion
he's kissing he's going to do a kissing
my mom video all right here we go
and by the way by the way this is
literally look at look in the mirror i'm
shooting this on my iphone this was all
spur of the moment my mom was here and
none of the cameras were ready so it's a
shot on my iphone doing it for you guys
all right so the cameras are scissors
all right
rock rock paper scissors mommy
wait no let's try again here we go rock
paper scissors
i won that time
all right how are we going to angle this
here we go
[Laughter]
all right here we go
i was like trying to stop this here we
go
oh my god
even in italy i feel like they're more
it's mommy make out there's more
affectionate than chris and with his mom
and this epic dare
can i chime in on this because yes
that's not really your europe thing
i just want to stand up for all the
european foot soldiers here okay okay
love do you how do you greet your mom
love
at maximum with a hug maybe yeah i mean
that's the thing i feel like i'm from
israel and people are pretty warm you
fist your mom when you say hi
come on ethan what about the fact that
your parents named you love
right
you were saying yeah i don't know i'm
saying that
um
i'm used to people
being pretty warm
but it would not be in that kind of wait
that's like too
too much
sexy well let me let me just say like
because i'm trying i'm just really
trying to put myself in that frame of
mind but like to touch someone's face
like this and then to put like do this
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
speaking of which
to touch you like that and by the way
damn girl
dude your your nails look so good have
you showed those yeah i did it's still
the same i'm gonna need to last really
long it's amazing yeah this gel stuff is
amazing i'm kind of super late super
late to the game that's hot
well likes it oh
so can we talk about anything going on
in your life specifically listen there's
a little tension here
there's a little awkwardness because
there's something going on
that we don't know if we should talk
about and i don't want to make elon
comfortable but there's something
happening
and you guys may have noticed we
originally titled it elo's big
announcement but then we changed it to
james charles birthday
so there is some tension
should we should we just break should we
just break the and i'm drinking a diet
coke here i'm celebrating
i usually don't do
coke zero on the show
all right but i'm celebrating um
well
so
i don't know yet for sure
we don't know
but ninety-five percent
i
right
maybe
maybe
we're like sharing it way too early no
one in their right mind will show you're
right anyone yet you're right but i
think because of the journey we've
always been so upfront yeah the whole
time with the journey and the ins and
outs and the ups and downs
we shared the last time early too yeah
so with that being said
[Music]
let's just say i did not get my period
[Music]
aka i think you can hit the what up
[Music]
what up
that's as
[Laughter]
[Applause]
see i feel bad celebrating so much what
if it's not yet you know but it's no so
here let me explain why it's more than
just you missed your period
yeah yeah yeah
first of all
we've been
doing the insemination thing
or yeah
and i felt this month
it was a good month like when i went in
there to nut in the cup i was like that
was a good load
[Laughter]
i felt good about that load
to this tiny little office
with wax paper and some dudes sitting
one foot outside the door closed
and i nutted in that plastic cup and
closed it and wrote down the time
i thought that was a good one
and so from that moment i had a good
feeling about it but the thing is last
time we tried the um fertility treatment
on you yeah
you got your period early
um
not exactly
did i i don't think it was early you got
it like because we the she's like you'll
know if you're pregnant in two weeks and
then you got your period after one week
or yeah it wasn't two weeks yet yeah
and so this time
the two weeks passed
two weeks was on thursday but here's the
other wrinkle you've been peeing on the
stick and we've been getting faint
second lines ethan keeps telling me
because i keep forgetting so he's like
go pee on a stick so now theodore says
it oh yeah
and so the thing that really convinced
me more than anything is because when
she's peeing on the stick the second
line means pregnant yeah there's a faint
second line every time she pees on the
stick yeah so i'm like thinking no
period we got faint second lines
powerful load
i'm thinking i'm putting the one-on-one
together on this
and i think we did it
but
let's just see
because
you might get a call during the show
why i did a blood test today she did a
blood test this morning with the
fertility doctor
so we're expecting their call
but so yeah it's just that i don't know
i've been like it's such a emotional
um roller coaster because i'm also on
hormones and
i feel like everything is uh
crazy so
it would just i don't want to like get
too depressed if it didn't happen so
that's why i also don't want to get too
excited
that's the same that's like the same
explanation that's obvious right but i
think first of all i take responsibility
i get too excited i got too excited
and then i told everyone and then i
started like telling the guys and then i
had to be like well i better tell my
parents if i told the guys
and then my mom immediately called me
and he was like is no we don't know for
sure like 95 percent
but so and then the other thing is
because we're like oh you don't want to
jinx it
no that i don't care about because last
time we told really early with theodore
yeah
and we got an angel
so
pretty epic
thank you
so um
but yeah so to everyone that's been
wondering and guessing in the chat
because i saw
all kinds of comments and then people
were like well don't make assumptions
um so yeah that's what it was about the
title
last night and then i told ethan you
gotta change that yeah she got mad at me
well it kind of started as a joke
because i was like i was like i said
jokingly ela's pregnant for the title
and then dan and then dan was like how
about
italy's big announcement and i was like
yeah i like that keep it vague keep a
little bit of click bait there yeah
and then ela's like are you [ __ ]
serious you can't title with that and i
was like oh you're right i'm sorry i'm
getting too excited
i just want that call i don't honestly
don't care about this show right now
it's hard to do the show because i just
want to know but but you are i know you
are but we need to we need like that
doctor like yes
but because usually when you're about to
get your period you get sore and stuff
but you didn't you don't have any of the
periods sign yeah
that powerful load and i'm hungry
what do you want you want no no are you
hungry right now no i just went in
general okay in general
[ __ ] fried chicken
i was about to end the show no
because i gotta make sure you get in the
calories she needs you know what i mean
cookies for you
no no no
okay
anytime you just tell me
okay i'll end the show right now
um
so
um
that's what's been going on
pretty exciting
i think it's going to be another boy eli
i hate to break it too funny you keep
saying that and i don't think so i think
it's gonna be a girl i'd love for it to
be a girl but i just think i feel like
we're just one of those families just
gonna have all boys i don't know
i'd love to have a little girl though
you know don't get me wrong
so
dang you're wrong
well
anyway um we're going and then you know
we're going to um
disneyland
this week for theodore's second birthday
and now if you now that you're pregnant
can you is there like restrictions on
the rise now right yeah even from the
very beginning it's like boop you're
pregnant no rides yeah i can do some
i mean we're just going to do the fun
easy little ride yeah
dj khaled
none of that no jet ski fun
rides another one throwback
how many kids total do you want someone
is asking in the
in the chat i want three
i me too three
but you might have twins too that's the
crazy thing ability right is that she
has like a ten percent chance of having
twins yeah that's part of the triplets
bro
no you what if we had triplets i think i
just have to retire
like i have no time for work
i can't sorry everybody i literally
can't do this
triplets
would be would be kind of nice to get
twins though because you're like done
you're like i'm done yeah we're done i'm
out should i tie my how do you know some
dudes do that how do you carry two
you don't you don't have tubes i think
that's the woman that does what do the
guys do you get a vasectomy yeah we're
going to get a snip the women do the
tubes should i say right are you stupid
i'll snip you do enough
i don't know i did i would do any of
that oh you just see like god's plan
yeah
okay i like that i'll have more kids
frankincense because we've had such a
struggle to get pregnant it's like how
are you gonna say no right that's a good
point
if it if god just puts like uh
immaculate conception
you're gonna see the power of god
because why aren't you kind of like
unplanned
i think i i was unplanned too yeah so
it's like i'm crazy you know the crazy
thing about my conception is that
i may have told a story a while ago but
when my mom she
i'm much younger than my
younger than my sister
no i'm 10 years from my brother right
right but seven from the
middle yeah
so my my uh
conception
yeah sounds weird i've conceived of you
my child
sounds like biblical
um
my mom had cancer and she didn't know it
she had thyroid cancer and she went to
the doctor because she was getting sick
she didn't know she was pregnant she's
like what's wrong with me and she's like
oh you're pregnant and also you have
this lump here which we need to check
out
and so um
my mom she she they're like what do we
do so one one doctor
the first doctor was like you need to
have an abortion
so that we can do deal with the can the
chemo treatment
because we can't do chemo while you're
pregnant we'll kill the baby
and she's like that doesn't so she went
to another doctor and got a second
opinion and he's like that's [ __ ]
insane that the doctor told you to get
an abortion he's like he called
apparently the second doctor even called
the other doctor and bitched him out
like that wow inappropriate sometimes
it's so important to get that second
opinion absolutely when you just have
that gut feeling of like wait what
you're telling me sounds insane yeah
like i had one dentist that was like you
gotta redo your whole mouth was that in
israel or yeah in israel
and i was like my teeth are fine what
are you talking about he's like we have
to pull all your keys
yeah some like totally
lunatic [ __ ]
and then the other dentist was like you
have one cavity yeah
but yeah so your mom was a badass
because she she
gave birth and then went through chemo
right my mom was such a badass
that she basically carried me
and didn't get any treatment for the
cancer
until she gave birth to me and then she
got chemo and surgery she had her
thyroid removed yeah and i think she had
uh radiation or chemo i don't know that
she had
radiation and so she's cancer-free
obviously she beat the
she beat the cancer but um
that's so crazy but i can't but she like
you know
here i am and like after birth you're in
such a difficult
spot already yeah i think she had to go
straight into surgery that's crazy
um
but so yeah that's why i'm kind of like
i don't know if i'm really even ready to
even think about like
um advice like to me or whatever what do
you call it yeah
i'll take four i love it i love kids now
i grew up you know being four siblings
it's pretty fun i'll tell you what and
like
the good thing is is that we're in a
situation where we can support a big
family
so that's obviously good
i can imagine like if you are
financially strained that it could be
really stressful having yeah a lot of
kids but honestly you
you
make through
even if you're not well off i mean
that's how i grow up well yeah yeah yeah
you know i know
but it can add a lot of stress you know
sure
so like i'll have 4k i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll just have five kids bro let's move
to let's just go start a mormon family
i don't know why mormons they have a lot
of kids
those mormons are fertile as [ __ ] bro
they have like crazy families
god's like we need mormons now
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
thank you joe
i hope my kids can jump on your lap
someday
and the hair hairy legs
i got hairy legs
so now that you're pregnant what do you
want for lunch to celebrate
talking about what's really important
i don't know
mexican no italian
oh
easy always stops me at italian
or what's left barbecue chicken
deli
fried chicken [ __ ] fried chicken
[ __ ] fried chicken let's think about
it later yeah this is the end of the
show discussion yeah
listen this this conversation is
important and he's pregnant we're not
going back out he's eating uh we are at
30 minutes so we should do our ad
reading
oh let me see my family's messaging me
let me see oh no they're talking about
caterpillars
they did call me 24 minutes ago
i just wondered if my parents were
watching and so i was being like we're
pregnant 95
all right let's talk about dick wipes
speaking of getting pregnant you're
gonna love this one
this one is roman dick wipes
seriously hold on they're not called
dickway
they're called swipes that is right dick
swipes
give it a swipe you're good to go
why are we swiping our dicks boys
it says please show the product on
camera i don't have the product do i
nope they did not send it to us not
showing your product we have not tried
open the swipe we have a website they
have a website dan that we can cut they
sure do it's get roman.com h3
uh we 10 off your swipes we got a link
in the description all right what are
these swipes most guys have tried
different ways to last longer
is this the direction you thought it was
going
but thinking about it
some guys think about baseball they
count to ten they say a pledge of the
legions
in fact there was one great viral video
do you remember where he says i think
about my mom
okay and everybody clowns on him forever
they're like why do you think about your
mom during sex was it the dude that we
were watching earlier in the italian
gang
no he's like no no i have sex with my
mom i think about my grandma to make me
last longer
that's why the folks at roman
and online men's health company are
changing the game with the roman swipes
the secret to la to longer lasting sex
roma swipes are clinically proven way to
last longer in bed they're effective
easy to use and fast acting but they and
they don't even require a prescription
dan you did some research this is the
real deal right
yeah i mean
apparently it's um by the way i'm trying
to find that video and all that's coming
up is porn in my search oh my god
mom mom and it's unborn it's on his
screen
love is like looking over here
i'm not clicking on it i'm just i'm just
saying um
yeah no i mean it it's
been clinically trialled and all of that
and uh with control group the whole
shebang the same thing this ain't your
uh gas station uh
fix you know
the dudes who swipe last longer it's
that simple
uh roman swipes yeah yeah yeah uh
swipes are great they will not transfer
to your partner so you can last longer
without worrying
uh roman swipes
are discrete
unmax unmarked package and each swipe
package is small enough to hide in your
wallet
okay guys now i just gotta make sure you
know this if you're swiping your dick
don't let the girl see because that's
odd
i'll be honest it looks odd go to the
bathroom do it in private if it's like a
first date you mean a first date and you
start it looks like you're cleaning your
[ __ ] with the baby wood you don't want
that well you're assuming they're not
talking about it maybe it's a couple in
there no if it's a couple and you guys
been together great yeah i'm saying
you're like sleeping with the girl for
the first time
for some reason that's when i imagine it
when you would need it the most but what
do i know
but like yeah just use it discreetly you
don't want
that's not a good conversation starter
hey baby i got these romans for later
they're super easy to use guys
just take the swipe out of the pack
swipe it on let it dry and you're good
to go if you guys want to last a little
bit longer go to get
roman dot com slash h string get ten
dollars off your first order of swipes
plus free two day shipping make sure you
click the link in the description to get
ten dollars off swipe so you can start
having
longer sex
you know it's funny um
[Music]
yeah or you could just take
antidepressants i was saying that [ __ ]
makes my dick feel like a potato
all right
it works though clearly
um did you guys find that clip of the
guy saying he fantasized about his mom
bunch of porn like any search result of
mom thinking of mom
sex anything it's going to be porn
search results
someone was like oh god there's oh oh it
was from a porn that's why
no but it was like an e-fucked video
it's not like pornography okay
he finishes like super super fast
right and then they're like man you
didn't last very long he's like i know i
was trying so hard i was thinking about
my mom
and what he meant is like i was trying
to like think about something to make me
laugh longer but what came out is like i
was thinking about my mom and everyone
was like what the [ __ ] yeah
you had to see it
get out of here
yoko
jesus
all right um
so anyway we actually have james charles
on the phone i wanted to ask him about
really do we have james uh we do i'll uh
i'll let him on the call right now do
you want to show his instagram oh i
guess we did it earlier
yeah i showed it show it again just for
the for the highlight clip so i wanted
to talk with james today about um
just how like it must be so nice to know
that he can like
prey on so many people and just get away
just be like totally fine you know
and i just wanted to get some insight of
how he's feeling and how he's doing so
if he's uh whenever he's available
i'd love to catch up with him uh james
are you are you there james hi sisters
james thank you for calling in man how
are you have you been
i've been good i just finished up a
party at brian singer's house for my
birthday oh no
wait isn't brian singer
the guy
he was from that documentary an open
secret he had like parties with underage
boys and drugs and stuff
yeah it was really fun
oh jesus man
i gave all the kids pikachu face paints
stop it
are you surprised i have to ask like
what are the sounds in the background
are those the sounds are is that like
their garden yeah are you are you
somewhere right now james
oh my god um
absolutely not i mean ever since
ever since the scandal i've just been
laying pretty low
um at a ball pit in chuck e oh my god
you're in a ball pit at chuck e cheese
as we speak i've just been sitting here
watching waiting and by the way those
aren't the only balls i've had on my
chin this weekend
are you surprised james by how many
people are liking your birthday post
because you probably thought you were
canceled right
i mean it's amazing like how many people
don't care like at all about this kind
of thing when you're famous
what is
my birthday post it had two million
likes right
yeah you can cancel me but not my
birthday
does it encourage you at all that your
fans have been so forgiving it's almost
like hey i can do whatever i want right
um wait what was that
hold on um right now i'm ordering lunch
hold on yes one large chuck e cheese
pizza and a paw patrol
[Laughter]
you serious bro
that is so brazen of you to celebrate
your birthday at chuck e cheese
i just do what i can i
i'm just really excited i'm really
excited so you i feel like maybe you
feel like you've been you've been
forgiven and even vindicated by your
fans 2.1 million likes you're not
wasting any time i guess
i'm not wasting any time at all i'm just
i'm just here in chuck e cheese i'm
signing pizzas i'm just super excited to
meet all my fans that happen to be you
know 16 to 21 whatever
well
listen
i don't mean to be rude or forward james
but
i personally think that you should
probably be in jail
not enjoying yourself at chuck e cheese
bill cosby and harvey weinstein had all
their fun for like 30 years before they
went to jail so why should i go to jail
who's that in the background james yeah
oh
oh my god wait
are the fbi there at chuck e cheese oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
can you believe the balls on this guy
that he's celebrating his birthday at
chuck e cheese in the ball pit yeah it's
pretty like you said that's pretty
brazen
like he said you get you cannot cancel
his birthday
2 million likes
he had a good point when he's like it's
kind of crazy how nobody cares about
this stuff
wow
that is shocking
well actually interestingly too
we have the president uh trump is has
his own allegations trump too and yeah
wanting to weigh in um
on the situation i didn't really know
that he was
following the whole james charles yeah
situation but he's always you know he's
he on the beauty pageant he's always
kind of been right in in the beauty
world he's kind of he's kind of glam
himself all right married a model he's
definitely got a glam squad right well
how many accusers does trump have he has
like
oh
it's hard to keep up but why don't we uh
just ask him ourselves uh guys i think
he's here yeah thank you
hello
can you hear me is this on yes it is
yes it is hello everybody
hold on one second i gotta take my
energy drink
mayonnaise oh my god yeah
miracle what it's like a thick energy
drink oh my goodness really good holy
[ __ ]
it's from their president trump's going
to toe-to-toe with me
hello you joe
well
thanks for calling back in i really
appreciate that we we just got off the
phone with james charles actually he
isn't he great isn't he fantastic what a
great kid what a great kid when he just
earned whatever he turned yeah 22 i
think 22 22 lucky lucky bastard
you know
um
he was at a chuck e cheese
celebrating his birthday
isn't that great isn't that great about
the people who love him the most
[Laughter]
don't you think it's a little
inappropriate that he was celebrating at
chuck e cheese after all not really it's
free refills and i i i love any place
with free refills right
i didn't i hadn't thought about that
angle
yeah that's great the puppet the puppet
who doesn't love balls you know what i
mean i know he does sir they love the
balls
he's going to go very very far because
you know i and by the way by the way by
the way i love the gays i love the gays
it's pride month it's pride month
they're the ones who do my hair and make
me look so good that's true it is pride
month we should be respectful it is
pride month right so
he just got arrested from by the fbi
i think he just got arrested yes see
this is the problem
the law enforcement of this country is
out of control they did it to rudy they
did it to roger stone they did it to
paul manafort they're doing it to all my
friends i think it's really really
horrible the way the police just go
absolutely crazy
do you think it's a coincidence at all
that they're arresting everyone around
you
uh you know i never really thought of
that till right now that it's kind of
strange when you think about it it's
kind of because my other attorney
michael cohen they arrested him too so
that's really really hot but it's all
fake news by the way
fake news it's fake news you know james
is a wonderful wonderful guy and these
allegations of grooming are just they're
just blown out of proportion
and by the way that's what he does he
grooms he grooves that's true i mean he
is
maybe the police misunderstood they
thought he was grooming kids he's great
exactly exactly you know it's not like
it's illegal to send uh dick pics to
anybody you know what i mean billy
spitzer did it and weiner did it you
know the guy so i would never do it i
would never do it because you know that
i could sell those and make a lot of
money i'd never send them for free right
right sure well are you are you able to
pardon james is that something that's in
your power well not only pardoned which
i do have right here i have the james
charles pardon ready to go
here's the seal it's framed this is a
very expensive costco frame this isn't
the cheap way this is a good frame
because you buy three of these at a time
because i gotta frame for him and we're
working with some very wonderful
wonderful people you know i'm a real
estate guy and a marketing guy and
epstein island is up for sale so
we can make it jade
james charles island or or listen to
this listen to this you're gonna love
this here you know what his full name is
you know what his full name is no
his name is james charles dickinson oh
that could be dickinson island oh
dixon it's perfect because then the
marketing match is what happens there no
no no
no
absolutely mr president that is entirely
inappropriate or we could go with
charles island and it could be like
charles in charge which is a tremendous
tv show with my good friend
he's a big right-wing guy so
one so now that you've written him a
part and by the way mr president um
you're i don't know if you knew but
you're not currently the president are
you able to write james pardon legally
oh no this is one of the ones i saved
this is the this is the last one this is
the last blank you know obama
thousand i only wrote 243. this is 243.
wow
this is it this is double doubled in
value doubled in value but someone like
he deserves he deserves to be saved he
deserves to have a presidential pardon
he's a great guy he's misunderstood he
loves children like bill cosby and and
michael jackson so i think we need
people like that we don't know
well since you're
this is i mean he's going to be really
happy to hear that are you planning to
celebrate with james uh once he gets out
of prison
oh never i'd never be in a photo with
that guy
overall i think he's a wonderful
wonderful guy but i think he's a good
you know cause like i can't be in all
these photos with all these people i
mean every time i take a photo they say
i'm really good friends with somebody
which is not necessarily true like
jeffrey epstein there was one exactly
just because i was in 50 60 photos with
jeffrey epstein and all his private chat
people are like oh you guys would be
good friends i barely knew the guy
and michael cohen he was my executive
vice president for 12 years basically i
saw him once or twice
and your son even probably people say
you guys are close like uh eric trump
i i really don't know where
right
that's what it seems like i see him walk
by my office and i'm like who's that guy
i try not to get too involved with these
people right you're not going to be
there
the [ __ ] is she something else what a
knockout yeah
you know i don't know if you saw we were
watching um
with these tick tocks where the mom was
or the son was getting really familiar
like really sexual with his mom have you
seen anything is that like if you watch
pornography could you give me the
address for those because i think that'd
be fun to watch i have a lot of time on
my hands now oan is tired of
interviewing me right right oh and by
the way by the way this goes back to uh
james charles again i think it's very
brave of him very brave of him to admit
that you forced him to rip off your
hoodie i thought that was very very
difficult oh yeah
thank you thank you very much i think
you're who are you complimenting i'm not
sure if you want to thank him for that
actually oh well
he was brave he admitted to whatever he
did yeah
i'm very honored it's a deep cut
yeah they're very they look very similar
to those two hoodies
well
mr president somebody sent me a photo of
you on the uh on the gatsby i have to
get you
i'd love to cruise on the gatsby with
you someday come to mar-a-lago and we'll
run over all the rich old people that i
want to get rid of nice
i'd love to well thank you for the
invite thank you for your time is there
anything else you want to say mr
president before we part ways well i saw
the love backed i even just saw it right
now and i think it's tremendous could
you imagine an army of me
invading some town somewhere some you
know left-wing town just hundreds and
hundreds of trumps i think it's
tremendous i'd love to see that it's
like a trump rally you're describing
yeah
yeah it's a reverse trump rally it's
just a lot of me that's right
no one else
well you guys were great i always love
being on i'm going to get back to my
miracle whip it's delicious it goes down
chunky and thick which i like thank you
thank you mr president stay good stay
busy uh we'll see you in uh twenty
twenty on the other side of memorial day
yes yes yes of course
yeah of course
wow
the president calls him to this show
yeah
what an honor i don't think he's
kind of not welcome on most shows at
that point as my kind of imagine yeah
right
he wrote james charles a presidential
pardon
how good fortune for james
[Applause]
uh speaking of which ela you want to see
okay tell me what you think of this
because us guys trying to make whatever
this is
i don't think you've seen it
so
tell me what you think
is that your decimal checker no
oh my god y'all
i'm in his [ __ ] monster truck look at
this [ __ ]
all these speakers everywhere
the [ __ ] is going on
okay so okay you want to watch it one
more time
here one more time checker no
oh my god y'all
i'm in this [ __ ] monster truck look
at this [ __ ]
all these speakers everywhere
what and this doesn't look so good
so
yeah so there's huge speakers yeah
and some tormented soul
[Laughter]
it's got to be a doll
it looks like some halloween left over
but it looks so high quality at the same
time yeah i think it's just part of the
design of the truck it scared the [ __ ]
out of me when you showed me this
you think it's part of the truck yeah i
think so
are you just put well regardless i hope
it looks super really
but it's not a real person
well we're just hoping and praying it's
not
i mean the mannerism is perfect though
someone who's tormented by huge
speakers shame we never got to hear the
speakers well you know i went to her
account and i was like is this just some
goof account but here's what makes me
think like what the hell
her videos
are nothing like that one you would
think like it was a setup by some like
prankster she's just some random lady
so what is does what do you think about
that dan
is there more with the car is this the
one we just watched yeah your adjustable
checker no
so what do you think about that dan and
then here here's the next video what the
[ __ ] listen to this y'all
blaster what you doing these speakers go
holy [ __ ] the top comment is addressed
the demon pleaser
oh my god
oh here let's see if she dressed the
demon watch this
[Music]
how is she not addressing the demon
though all the comments are about it
dude her hair is shaking yeah
she never addressed the demon
and now she's just making videos about
jewelry you see how weird it is
it's not a setup
i did not see that [ __ ] monster thing
in the back of that truck all i was
thinking about was the speakers and i
had been having some fun but next
tuesday i get to see the owner of that
truck again and i'll be doing another
video she didn't see it what
hell no
yeah
but that's okay wait wait here's a
follow-up
i need help speaker's got me [ __ ] up
if he they said if he comes back on
tuesday and it's missing i'm gonna lose
it
oh my god
that thing is pretty badass i think it
has got to be part of the car what a
legend though wow
do you think it's an actual demon like
what's the alternative okay it's part of
the car's design how do you think you
get speakers that loud you summon a
demon
[Laughter]
it's keemstar
that's what keemstar's soul looks like
um here's another one for you to break
down
oh this is what i saw this morning it's
kind of dumb but i just thought it was
great
i ignore the caption i've never seen
this they add in caption like we all
know this but
us teachers would never ask you students
to do anything we wouldn't do ourselves
what is happening i didn't know you're
just
he was supposed to hold it i guess but
she really didn't give him any warning
ourselves
i didn't know you're
oh my god i love like laughs in her face
too like doesn't even try to hide it
good [ __ ] right yeah
one more time teachers would never ask
you students to do anything we wouldn't
do ourselves
the commitment was so good
yo what the [ __ ] is this oh okay here's
another one you guys been wanting me to
watch this for so long
it's honestly just so gross that i never
um
i i was like this is too disgusting but
okay you got i'll just i give the people
what they want i'm a man of the people
oh
dude in a parking
lot puts his hand down his wife's pants
why don't we do ever do anything
exciting like that either what is this
this on the news
no it's just a viral video i don't know
what this channel is exclusive yeah this
ain't news bro exclusive
breaking news what's with this layout
okay here we go like comment share
so hand way down the pants
but guess who smells it her
no
she smells it
she smells it
either why don't we ever do anything fun
in public like that
i just i can't believe how long they're
doing it for in public
like even though it's so short it's like
it's crazy
i would expect he would smell it i think
it was such a twist that she smelled it
don't you
also that it seems like they already
it's true
they already have done it before oh this
is yeah yeah this is routine they're
pros
[Music]
yeah dude that it's just it's such a
twist to me that she smelled it
and is she that he's definitely in her
butt right not because you could reach
around and go to the front
girl what is wrong with you you need
jesus
hold on let me get the cube where's the
jewel
oh uh
it's probably on the other um
set
yeah give me that
i need jesus right now
jill lostin guys away
this ain't right what just we saw here
girl let's not watch it again though no
we're gonna watch it in slow motion
and get joel osteen's advice
playback speed
quarter
you need jesus all right guys
i'm about to save your soul because this
[ __ ] is [ __ ]
let's see a sermon i want to talk to you
today about
it's just a matter of time
we all have things that we're believing
will change
we're fighting an illness we're
struggling with an addiction we're
dealing with fear depression anxiety
we know what god promised that he would
receive he promised this that he would
free us from the fear
we prayed we believe but we don't see
anything improving
but what you can't see
is the moment you prayed in the undersea
you're supposed to smell it
of what was coming against you was cut
off
the source of the fear the source of the
addiction the source of the sickness now
you may not see any manifestation for
some time come on over here there may
not be any evidence that things have
changed
this is when many people get discouraged
but there will always be a period of
time dude
that is so intense
you think it's her kink or his
i think it's both yeah it's a mutual
yeah well so who's that your soulmate
whose idea was it
i i say the dudes it's usually the dudes
but the fact that she's smelling yeah
knows me think that it's her idea i
agree i agree i i think she
she came up with a modest proposal for
him and he and he was down the clock
what do you think she said like i want
you to finger my ass and then i want to
smell it or she just took a [ __ ] in
public
and he's doing it yeah you know i'm
doing a little one a dip stick yeah a
little one-two action it's definitely
her why would she smell it sir
i'm you know i assume it's a fetish you
know you guys ever been asked to do
anything weird in bed because abe you're
like oh it was her like i was like i
mean that's pretty alpha as [ __ ] to be
like
put your hand in my eyes it's a control
thing i think oh that's true she
alphabet the [ __ ] out of him
that's a good observation yeah yeah i
see that abe understands power dynamics
he understands it well
what's the kinkiest [ __ ] that anyone's
ever roped you guys into doing
uh
nothing anywhere approaching that i'll
tell you
yeah my love life's been pretty vanilla
i i i did i did fist ela's ass once at
the zoo
and i let the gorilla smell it
but that's it that's that's as crazy as
we've got
i bet zach's got up to weird [ __ ] huh
well this whole thing kind of reminded
me of a story he told on the podcast oh
when he ate out a girl's stinky's ass on
a hike it's really not too far off from
this
i'm right it's not that far off well but
it's not in public he went straight to
the source right it was in public they
were hiking no no he said when they got
back no he said on the trail wait on the
trail yeah exactly i'm not talking about
it he's not talking
it was on the trail oh that is okay
yeah that's kind of on the same level is
that alpha as [ __ ] ab
you tell me bro
yeah zach said he wants eight out of
girls sweaty [ __ ] after a long hike
on the trail see when i yeah the way i
recall the story after i just assumed
like
back back
i remember it being on the trail yeah me
too
okay that's the story okay did you did
anyone see you did you go off the trail
or were you i'm not talking okay
shutting this down
zach's back in a relationship so he's
keeping things close to the best
i'm and i'm happy for you by the way
thank you thank you i appreciate that
he only eats mayo now
he doesn't he doesn't talk about
inappropriate things
speaking of mayo did you guys
update on oh the mayo thing
you missed a lot elo yeah okay so we've
been at war we did it we talked about it
not off the rails but oh cause they
snubbed us some of off the rails but i
guess i missed that part it was in the
it was in the back half i think they
snubbed us they said
here's our eight finalists and then they
even went as far as to send a dm to the
podcast twitter saying
listen you're an honorable mention we're
gonna give you a free shirt and a year's
worth of mayo but you didn't make the
cut
[ __ ] and then we found even deeper
conspiracy is that bar stool sports is
somehow involved
and the mayonnaise covers
yeah dave pork boy is i mean
we are there's a little bit of
speculating so um you know i don't want
to i don't want to say anything that
gets us in trouble
you know we have enough lawsuits on our
hands as it is but um
but dave pork boy definitely stole it
yeah he's exactly yes he's definitely
involved it's his fault
[ __ ] him
see that's what i'm saying it starts to
get a little anti-semitic when you play
pig sounds
tell me what you think because
he's jewish
so if you call him pork boy and then you
start making pig sounds it sounds like a
coaster joke
yeah i could see that they thought i was
crazy but i was like this seems a little
anti-semitic yeah well i didn't even
know he was jewish come on look at the
guys
what do you have blind
sorry sorry who's hannah medic here
who's sandy cemetic here
jesus
that guy's like every douche douchey jew
i knew in hebrew school
they all look like that
there's nice jews there's good jews like
me and adam sandler and then there's
you know dave pork boy right
well
his name sounds like pork i don't know
what to say it's not a jewish thing
yeah
um
okay this next topic is pretty weird ela
all right and
i i have a hard time believing it's real
thing it's called harry potter reality
shifters
and apparently there's kids
that believe that harry potter is real
and that they can will their way
into the world of harry potter correct
me if i'm wrong not so much that it's
real but they could create it they could
make that they can make it real they can
make it real within their mind
are you sure it's not so elaborate like
role playing
oh no
that was sort of our impression at first
but as we dug in um they
they take it a little bit it's it's
definitely several steps beyond fan
fiction or uh fantasy so
where'd you find it what is it i it kept
popping up i kept seeing uh
uh videos pop up on like twitter and
stuff of um
people being like what the [ __ ] is going
on with gen z
uh
i thought i was like i'm team gen z i
like znz but i mean this is definitely a
mark against the whole generation
if if i'm if i'm gonna believe this is
actually not an elaborate troll but
you'll see that they have quite a lot of
like 160 000 likes so it has a lot of
engagement so
here let's watch this one if you're part
of shift talk
you know that we like the affirmation i
am in my desired reality
if you're a part of shift talk you know
that we like to use the affirmation i am
in my desired reality and a lot of
people say that that's the affirmation
that gets you to your desired reality in
the end but when i used to say it i
would be like okay well i'm not actually
in my desired reality so
i'm just saying this to trick my mind
think about it like this my finger is on
the lantern right this is what it looks
like when i have both my eyes out this
is what it looks like with my left eye
closed this is what it looks like with
my right eye closed so is my finger
really on the lantern or is it over here
who's to say can you be in more places
than one at the same time
who's to say it's all about perspective
sure with both eyes open and with my
left eye closed
it may look like my fingers on the
lantern but if i close my right eye
i'm somewhere else
all i had to do was blink like close an
eye that's why everyone's like shifting
is so easy because you're just putting
yourself in a different
reality you're changing the perspective
think about it like that
if you're a part of something like that
hold on this is not
this is not comedy
and that's what i'm trying to figure out
they're saying no i think we have to
make a distinction but the top the
comments are like wait this makes so
much sense to me girl you changed the
whole game and don't you
wait but she's like dressed as hermione
and she's pretty old too by the way
she's not that young
well
gen z the the upper echelon of gen z is
in their uh early to mid twenties now
yeah i mean it's but don't you think
she's a little old to be role playing
well she's not in cosmic early 20s
probably i think anybody over 12 is
probably too old to be doing this let me
sample something else you haven't
shifted yet okay let me put you on this
method that literally oh my gosh
to my mutuals
like shift using a variation so wait
shifting is just to clear so shift that
shift
this is that's the shorthand for when
you shift is when you've now
entered this new reality okay so what is
shift shifting is when you're transport
your subconscious mind from your current
reality they call it a cr
to your desired reality known as dr
right there's no such thing as the coin
right right true
that is true
desired reality is not a dream it is
real and contains real people
time moves differently when shifting
three days can be one hour so they're
just like meditating what does it mean
they just sit there and then it seems
like it's it's like a very intense or or
uh um i've seen people compare it to
like lucid dreaming but um but while i
wake up yeah um
i
i have a theory and i'm gonna piss off a
lot of them but
i think they're trying to do this
because there's a lot of planning and
meditating and i think
sometimes they fall asleep and they're
just dreaming right
wow and they've just like kind of
convinced themselves that uh
something um something mystical is
happening guided like when they do
guided like yeah guided meditation kind
of foundation yeah they tell you like
all right so you're now in your favorite
place and we're at hogwarts imagine the
beers deep in you
and there's birds right noises
whatever you do that at therapy i've
done that
yeah do you think that your therapist
could convince so either doing this
therapy were they hypnotizer i actually
haven't really seen anything like when
like i haven't had it visual next time
you go will you ask them to bring you to
your desired reality do you want to work
yes
okay if it were yeah
and that's the thing is i'll say like
hey have you heard about shifting she's
like yeah
and it's not all harry potter
you know this this you can go to
whatever fantasy realm that you want but
the
from what we can tell the vast majority
are trying to get to hogwarts and
what you just kind of alluded to about
harry being deep inside you oh
there's a lot of this seems to be sexual
like for real the motivation is to get
there to [ __ ] draco malfoy or whatever
yeah
there's a lot of videos about draco wow
i mean not universally i don't want to
put them all in the same bucket i didn't
know he was the heartthrob of the harry
potter well i i well there is a lot of
draco they call it draco talk right i
didn't yeah they called some of them
called draco talk i didn't know he was
the heartthrob either but i guess uh how
is he the hard thing rob maybe they just
want the place that he's the bad boy
right yeah i'm gonna come he's tom
felton he's the guy yeah i mean
you want to look up some draco fanfic no
i mean also he's so young in that movie
look at him he's like a child
well they get older but the
audience are they're also child
age so they look up to their you know
okay
i'm still not entirely sure this isn't
just an elaborate like role-playing
thing
here how is shifting the hogwarts real
according to fantasy fans on tick tock
you can harry potter fans on the app
have recently been reality shifting to
place themselves in the magical world
world of hogwarts in reality shifting
you can insert yourself into the
alternative reality through precise
planning and meditation
how to shift
such a bizarre take on this whole thing
it's like you're just
you're just
meditating and imagining something like
well who wouldn't i feel like every kid
when you watch harry potter you're like
i wish i was a wizard yeah but it's like
you know of course fortunately
we are you're you're not a you're a mug
blood all right
you're a [ __ ] muggle dude yeah when i
was uh
telling my girlfriend about this
that was her responses like when i was a
kid this was just called fantasizing
like yeah i mean we all wanted to be
wizards sure yeah y'all are taking it
way too far bruh
this is like q and on for like harry
potter nerds
it's like damn the internet really
brought these people together it is kind
of a massive thing delusion uh
and it's you know it's it's escapism
obviously but just taken to the end look
they gotta face the music harry potter
is real and you're just a [ __ ] muggle
harry potter exists in our world they
got the magic they put the spells to do
the invisibility and your ass is just a
normal [ __ ] muggle you don't have
magic
face the music kid
you got you got shafted bro
i don't know
uh why like
give it like such an official title
shifting
shifting bear
well again i i don't know how deep we
want to go into it but but a b i mean
you were investigating it last night and
they get extremely specific in the
techniques like i'm about to read
somebody yeah you can uh you know
there's long instructions there's two
important factors in this there's the
script which is sort of what ela was
talking about which is planning ahead of
time talking about where you want to go
those types of things that calm you and
then there's the method so the script
and methods and then there's like four
uh popular methods so i don't know where
you want to start 69. i mean it's
totally like uh what my
this therapist that i was trying
right she was doing she has a script too
huh
i think they just need to take peyote
and all right
and you really plan that [ __ ] out there
you go
i'm doing a deep planning i want to be
in draco malfoy's closet
and he says bad girl
he sees me in the closet he says what
are you doing here
he ravages me and throws me on the bed
he's he casts a spell in my mouth so i
can't open my mouth
and then
and then
he casts a duplicate on himself there's
three of them and they all run rain on
me
[Laughter]
he duplicates himself into five people
he's then there's two in my butt two in
my
that's a four a quadruple penetration
and i say no draco no
i try to but my mouth is sealed
[Music]
[Music]
okay if you're a raven so apparently the
raven method actually let me watch this
video i wanna see what she was saying
this girl's a pro at it we gotta
interview her dan this method and i use
it to lucid dream it's all about
intention you know if you wanna shift
with it
you can shift with it if you want to do
lucid dreaming with it you can do that
okay
basically what you're gonna do go to bed
like normal
wake up early
then go about your day for a couple of
hours then go take a nap naps
[Music]
[Laughter]
and they
shift they don't do anything if you want
to include like a method you can like do
meditation tap into your senses try and
visualize yourself in your desired
reality and then fall asleep
whatever
but like naps do not underestimate them
i swear so many people like shift for
the first time during a nap
okay
by the way she's right about naps i mean
naps do rule naps
bruh bruh oh i mean i have the most
intensely insane dreams when i nap
maybe you're shifting dude
i'm gonna try to shift
i wake up in hermione's room
says what are you doing here
she duplicates herself
there's 20 hermiones
except it's her as an adult not as a
child
i'm writing a script yeah
i say no hermione no
and then it turns it starts turning into
a nightmare lose control and then she
takes out a strap-on
[Music]
and i say this isn't part of my dream
hermione and she starts
pounding me
no
okay i don't want to get too trigger
warning eh
um i'd love to reach out and try to
interview her
uh yeah i mean after this segment they
might
not be
too enthusiastic about coming on but
maybe they want to set the record
straight yeah maybe they want to set the
record straight one of the most popular
reality shifting methods is the raven
method this method involves
being in a starfish position on one's
bed and counting to 100 usually with
subliminal playing or with a positive
affirmation
said between numbers
uh
there's the alice in wonderland method
this method involves meditating
what's happening back here
the sign just randomly turned off we're
trying to turn it back on but don't
worry about it allison wonderland method
involves meditating and then laying on
your back and imagining yourself sitting
against a tree until someone from your
desired reality runs past you at which
point you're supposed to chase them
until you fall down the rabbit hole oh
boy
you are meant to find a key that will
unlock the door to your dr
the pillow method
the pillow method is another reality
shifting method gaining popularity
because it's relative simplicity it
involves um
just put it over your face until you
suffocate and pass out it's dying hey
the sign just turned back on whatever
writing down affirmations on a piece of
paper repeating the before bed and
sleeping with the paper under your
pillow i'll stop it there's a bunch of
these
wait with the paper under your pillow
yeah for the tooth fairy yeah
here i'm going to show you some of these
other ones we saw
um
here's a girl sharing her experience
wait there's a picture of james charles
is this what you guys meant
it said here's a pic this one says girl
shares her experience after shifting and
i click it and it's a picture of james
i'm gonna guess that's an heir but or
honey or is it yeah exactly
i want to be james charles on his 22nd
birthday after being accused of being a
predator
he's been cancelled by all of his
sponsors
and he's only has to go to chuck e
cheese for his final birthday well i'm
not saying he's dying sorry didn't mean
that
um
what is this like an old man
seeing my dad for the first time in
three years for me
but only a day for him
i loved hogwarts but let me tell you you
shift
you start to miss people
oh dude
that time works differently
oh
man
dude
holy [ __ ]
where's the one where the girl was like
i was scared to follow the voice it said
you're almost there where's that one
shifting 101 the raven method hey guys
so here's the raven shifting method step
one make sure that you're really tired
and kind of happy and again this isn't
like underground [ __ ] this is 124 000
likes
wow yeah
make sure you're not like sleeping
because i make that mistake a lot and
then i actually literally fall asleep
and then it actually fails number two
play some subliminals on your phone or
out loud number three get in a starfish
position no limbs are touching don't
move start to count to 100 with your
eyes closed once you hit 100 say isn't
that sleep paralysis between counting
each number visualize your dr it's okay
if your mind wanders a little bit but
try to regain that focus immediately
once you reach 100 you should stop
moving try to fall asleep and recite
some affirmations for example i have
shifted i'm in my dr i am waking up in
my dr remember to be calm and have
positive energy
i mean yeah that this is kind of just
lucid dreaming yeah people have been
studying how to lucid dream for a while
and it's probably something like this
i wake up and i'm in hagrid's hut
he's so powerful and so strong
and i say hagrid
tell me the truth
is your [ __ ] as big as the rest of you
and he says
he says
he slams it on the table with a giant
thud
his ale on the table falls over from the
massive thud of his 20-pound [ __ ]
what
and i say hagrid take me
he casts a spell on his dick grows even
bigger it's the size of me
now i'm hugging his dick like a body
pillow
enveloping my whole body
hagrid
daddy i turn into a i'm like a giant
fairy next to his giant man-made
[Music]
this is this is like a real fanfic
i'm the size of a fairy and i'm his man
and his giant hagrid [ __ ] daddy this is
a pulsating
and i'm riding it like a mystery saying
trisha would probably do um shifting
shifting yeah trish is the shifter for
sure how do i know oh
if i how do i know trisha didn't shift
here from hogwarts she's a hogwarts she
was she was making all those uh harry
potter tick tocks the other day yeah
yeah so maybe she's into it
how do we know we're not in the dream
world and she's shifted in here oh [ __ ]
what if hogwarts is real and we're
shifted into the history podcast right
now exactly holy [ __ ] i sort of feel
like i'm lucid dreaming right now yeah
anyway back to
yeah
i'm sorry
please really
and i said hagrid
get me a mug of bubble beer what do they
call it daddy bubble beer
butter beer beer
and i pour the butter beer all over my
body
daddy
now his [ __ ] is filling the whole hut
the windows are bursting from [ __ ] me
[Music]
gross
it's the door is blasted open from
cockpit
and it looks like a giant it looks like
a giant
tin can of spam
daddy chill
it's bursting open and i'm drowning
in hagrid's giant spammy [ __ ]
[Music]
someone said harry potter is slowly
being ruined for me well i was making
the same thing
you know what ruined harry potter for me
the last book
oh hot take hot take thank you you want
to ruin harry potter for me but the
first one okay slot one that's such a
hater okay
by the way it was it was just bad i'm
sorry but like i'm just gonna tell you
guys the ending of that book was
horrible yeah and i'll explain why
without spoiling anything i mean who
doesn't know how to answer it
he spends the whole book developing all
these characters and all this school
and the whole [ __ ] plot of the whole
story leading up to the final book is
thrown out the window because he has to
go find these relics
that's the only way you have to go find
these relics it's like okay what about
the six other books no and then there's
like a
last episode right where it's like years
later oh that was the worst bro don't
even get me started on the oh
i'm not following it was a happy ending
no that's bull that's so stupid
it's like oh and anyway they're like oh
everybody's dead and we discovered and
like people died and we we
freed whatever and then it's like fast
forward harry's kid is getting it's
going to hogwarts and everything's great
it's like i'm sorry who [ __ ] wrote
this 10 year old
i gotta i got a hot take i i hate or i
just dislike anything harry potter you
guys are all cynics take dan just said
yeah
dude
you said you don't like the first one no
i would
okay you had to read between the lines a
little bit zach
i'll have the hot take i like the happy
ending where everyone's happy
i know you like happy endings baby i
know that
do you guys know that there's a
character in harry potter of happy
endings i'm back in hagrid's hut
did you guys know that there's a
character in harry potter called
lucius
malfoy yeah he's a [ __ ] racist
lucius malfoy
okay what about it
what do you want from me it's the
dumbest [ __ ] name for a character
i've ever wizard bro
is he a bad guy
what a surprise the guy named [ __ ]
lucifer bad guy
i'm not gonna even say she's a good
writer because i read that whole book
and then at the end i was like oh she's
not that good of a writer
but people actually are criticizing her
a lot now because like there's one asian
character
or wasn't it harry's end up being his
significant other or was he get with
somebody else oh he got with ron's
sister anyway he was interested in this
asian character and her name was chen
and everyone was like oh really you
gotta name the one asian character chen
so there's that to deal with
anyway if i shift in there i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm imagining harry potter's world
i rewrite the ending it's way more
interesting
and better
her name was cho chang sorry oh yeah cho
chang it's like i'm sorry can you think
of a less like that much better than
what ethan said i said worse
hello my name is cho chang
it's like dude could you write like
maybe she doesn't need to be in cho
chang
i get their criticism on that i didn't
think about it at the time when i was
reading it
jacob rolling has had a million hot
takes right yeah she's apparently super
like
she hates trans people
it's like where did that come
like for someone who wrote such an
imaginary book yeah and it's all about
friendship and yeah overcoming the odds
as you could probably tell i'm not super
familiar with harry potter but didn't
she also get a lot of [ __ ] for there's
like a race of little goblin guys that
are obvious jews and they're all okay
i
i
i don't think i realized i didn't make
that connection personally i think she
also got shipped for that she did she
did
i
as a jewish person i i i didn't make
that connection they just seemed to me
like goblins and i think
in fantasy goblins have that reputation
and dwarves and stuff yeah i get it i i
i've just i just heard the second hand
that she had gotten a lot of flack for
that but i have heard that
but didn't she write a book about how
like a trans mer like some trans
person is a mass murderer and stuff i
think so yeah that was and it was under
like a pen name or something so people
didn't know it was her at first but
everyone figured it out yeah
she's a weirdo man yeah a little bit she
got so rich though what's your name
again
jk rowling and yeah
i think she's the richest author she's a
billionaire
well the yeah i mean listen
shifting on tick tock you will but those
books were yes a phenomenon listen
anything that gets people reading these
days is awesome
yeah they were a phenomenon oh i know i
know and i yeah she's a billionaire holy
[ __ ] i don't know why they just never
clicked for me even as a kid i always
liked fantasy and stuff do you like the
movies uh i haven't seen them all i've
seen a couple of them and they're good
some are okay i don't know i'm
exaggerating my hate for it i don't i
don't hate harry potter i just yeah it's
never been something i've been into
it's so crazy to me because it's such a
big deal for me growing up for most of
my friends like everybody around me was
always into it like you know there's no
one
i got the last book when i was first
leaving israel when i first met you
that's how long ago it was i bought the
book that just came out
in the airport store and it was like cut
throat rates i paid like 150 bucks for
it or something
and i was reading it on the way back
yeah
about that huh now i remember i forgot
that
did you guys find the one of the girl
being like i'm so close
but i'm afraid
because i still just have a picture of
james charles here guys
oh i don't know which one that is that
you're it was the first one dan sent it
was a girl being like i'm so i had
someone saying you're almost there but i
got scared and stopped oh uh oh yeah
give me a second i'm fine so anyway um
here's a script if you want to write a
script to gila you want to write a
script with me
okay my name is blank i am blank years
old my nickname is big salty balls
i was born in my zodiac sign i'm sorry
harry potter doesn't believe in zodiacs
they have real magic they don't need
that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this this is stupid my
blood type
oh my blood status well muggle obviously
anyone else
draco and i this is specifically about
giraco
there's a there's a script in here about
dracco
i just sent you what i the one that you
were looking for i'm pretty sure it's
it's this
um my personality my patronus my wand my
habits my love interest
do you play quidditch
i will not be able to suffer physical or
mental trauma and neither i nor anyone i
know will die oh okay that's reassuring
i do not need to study because i am
extra smart and never fail hell yeah
[Music]
my iq is 80.
i can speak
this is crazy detailed bro oh my
goodness
i am never late for class okay speak for
yourself why are you writing that why
are you writing that in for me
i have clear skin and healthy hair nails
let's go
talk about fantasy i have good friends
with everyone i'm good friends with
everyone at hogwarts
i do not bully people with a lesser
blood status to me okay sounds a little
[ __ ] snob to me
i am rich and can afford whatever i want
i have good breath all the time
did you do you found it dan
oh we got a technical issue
[Music]
i close my eyes
when i open them i'm in dumbledore's
office
oh my what are you doing here
i put my finger to his lips and i say
shh
i know what happens to you
oh people say dumbledore's gay
oh that's another thing she she did oh
she did like after the fact after the
books yeah she's like oh by the way he's
gay
okay they made a big deal out of it
i opened the and i say dumbledore
there's only one man i've ever wanted
[Music]
i go dumbledore i'm not gay but
i'm bi curious
and the chime sound is getting me every
time
and then dumb and then this is where it
always goes my fantasies dumbledore
casts a spell on his [ __ ] and it gets
huge and fills the room
that's the same script
his room the room fills with his [ __ ]
meat and blasts the doors and windows
out
i start drowning and dumbledore's
massive wizard [ __ ]
his [ __ ] is a horcrux
it has part of his soul and i suck it
out
i suck the horcrux out
he's never got dome like that before
and he says to me afterwards ethan
you may be a mug blood but that was
magical
okay cut it
thank you
thank you thank you thank you look at
alfredo
all right here's the one i was this is
the one that got me interested in this
to begin with
please enjoy this video i took at 3 40 3
40 a.m after accidentally shifting oh
[ __ ]
oh my god i just shifted i just shifted
this isn't the one i was thinking about
okay it's currently 3 40 in the morning
oh my god were you not just having a
dream
she said i literally woke up i wasn't
even trying to shift i would
you guys have me on snapchat okay so i
was in my dr for only three days but the
other night i was on snapchat wait
okay no no it was last night no i'm all
over the place last night you had a
dream and i was like or it was a few
hours ago wait what
[Music]
i was talking about how i they're just
goofing around oh my god uh yeah you
clicked on the one a b sent um uh
oh the massive one here yeah okay here
there's one like a spooky one here it is
this is awesome
look at two hundred thousand lights
[Music]
i almost shifted last night i was so
close and i heard a voice saying you're
almost there but i got scared and came
back i didn't expect it i'm so upset
that i got scared because of that voice
sounded so comforting and reassuring
you're almost there
i don't know why that voice made my
heart race
and why i can't stop thinking about it
is that even supposed to happen when you
shift
i think she might accidentally shift it
into hell
i think she just fell asleep
i think she shifted into
uh she shifted into
snape's
snapes okay under snape's bed
he casts a spell all right
it blows out the window and doors
all right enough of this
[Music]
interesting stuff though eh
we gotta get one of these people on i
need to know more about it
because these are not children these are
like young adults yeah
yeah sort of
early twenties a lot of them i mean i
i'm sure some are teen well yeah for
sure a lot of teenagers we purposely
so the neck we have actually really fun
uh ending
um how long we've been going down
we have been going oh my god the dogs
are losing their [ __ ] uh for about a
little over 90 minutes okay
good
so i have to pee really bad you want to
take it did you get a call from the
fertility doctor
no
they said they were going to call this
afternoon yeah
liars she called right before we went up
we're like here we go and she's like hi
i just have a question about billing i
was like oh yeah
i'm gonna go to the bathroom ela sanyo
now hmm i'll take you myself i got nada
anybody got some uh
well we already did talk about that
no harry potter fan fictions either
no
um any
chat things
somebody said uh read sonic fan fiction
they are mad funny yeah i'm aware of the
the whole sonic the hedgehog fandom um
being
i don't want to upset anybody but
a little weird
a little weird um i haven't delved that
deep to actually uh
read a bunch of them or anything like
that but um
but yeah i don't know what it is about
sonic the hedgehog that attracts uh a
certain type
bro have you seen amy no i'm kidding
okay
sonic is that the is that the hot
hedgehog the chick
hedgehog it is
thank you jay station
um
yeah what else my
stepdad is currently in the icu uh-oh
i watched ethan in love beat each other
up on off the rails and it was just what
i needed for that moment oh well
uh
peace and love and best wishes to your
stepdad and uh glad we could help you
out that was a lot of fun to shoot as uh
although
although i was i was genuinely worried
ethan was going to injure himself yeah i
know
like that i was you know i i was maybe
playing it up a little bit for camera
but
in the back of my mind i was like i
don't want to have to drive this dude to
the hospital right now it was scary i
mean he almost flipped it at one point
he did almost flip it at one point so
but it worked out everything's all good
mm-hmm and it turned out eel is maybe
even scarier on that thing so i have to
admit that when you get on that thing it
really does take over you you just want
to go fast and smash
elo
you [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and you like can't damage it there's
like virtually no damage i feel like
everything else is messed up
indestructible yeah the only real damage
all came from um from bobby lee which um
to any new viewers uh shortly after we
got the gatsby we had bobby lee on as a
guest and he
rammed it at full speed into the door
frame at our old office and uh
and almost
broke his leg i mean yeah to be quite
honest it was it was pretty intense yeah
and uh he [ __ ] it up pretty good but
other than that yeah
everything else is just kind of cosmetic
i had to kind of
bang
the bumper back into shape after bobby
because it was thanks damn
slammed into the tire
we were just uh recounting our gatsby
adventure the other day
someone else how do we feel about lord
of the rings we do love it love lord of
the rings love it love lord the movies
were perfect
yeah fantastic no we don't talk about
the hobbit movies though
the hobbit was such a dog [ __ ]
i was like so jack you know it's like
yeah me too but when i heard he was
putting the hobbit which is like
a short story into a three-part yeah
that was a bad song i was like no way
and when we watched i think we left i
don't think we even finished it
yeah we didn't finish it
the later ones are worse dude like the
first one is is probably the best one so
all right i think after the first one
we're still kind of open-minded yeah the
second one that we
the first one was okay yeah uh that well
the barrel thing is in the first one
actually
[Laughter]
it's so stupid yeah it's very stupid i
think i could be it's been a long time
i later i kept hearing people
made these fan edits where they took all
three and cut it into one movie i was
like oh that's interesting i bet that
could like
actually really improve it you just take
out cut out all the fat i watched it
still [ __ ] sucked out it really did
it's not you can't salvage that [ __ ]
there's so much wrong with that film
yeah like they were editing the plot to
make stretch it out yep creating
romances that didn't exist and these are
[ __ ] and then cutting out characters
that were actually interesting
so stupid
all right all right one last thing is
that they're asking for a fit check
feed check fit
that was not
not fair like f-i-t
f-i-t you guys still care
where you got sock stuff on your feet
i don't know where you're gonna put that
just for you guys
i don't have much to like
show off today but
oh fit check fit check my fit is nothing
just steady fret yeah
all right elas show it off come on girl
i have been loving wearing huge uh
t-shirts stand up show it off what this
is you're gonna be wearing huge t-shirts
from here on out for about nine months
but um i want to smell feet yeah not
much detail in today's fit you said you
want to smell feet
let me let me fish your [ __ ] come on
[Music]
um
oh
palm angels dipped
no
i thought this shoe was really
interesting and that's why i got that
there's a lot going on here
but yeah that's it give us a break
don't be shy stand up give us the world
there's not much to squirrel god damn it
you want to talk about stephen
crowder all right let's do it
so stephen crowder is one of these like
these like youtube conservative grifters
who like
i was telling dan i'm like i wish that i
would just be a conservative it'd be
like pretty much easy money it's the
easiest griffin that's like the game
every take is so obvious it's like
everyone has the same opinion
and if you even have like one gram of
like personality
then it's just like the easiest gift
ever you guys know stephen crowder from
these changed my mind things where he
goes to college campuses
and then debates like
children
poorly like not fully educate you know
in college you think you know [ __ ] but
you don't
this is like freshman in college i mean
come on
so he he does male privilege is a myth
changed my mind
stuff like that yeah i came across one
of these one time that just like was so
upsetting to watch
about like
yeah it's about like
i don't know
i don't even remember but something
about like gay
or
lgbtq
kind of topic you should find some other
good ones like maybe what you was
talking about it was it was really
annoying yeah they're all like they're
all
of his video you're talking about one of
his videos of him changed my mind i mean
they're they're all basically like a
little racist or misogynist or like
white nationally
which is kind of his flavor of content
but anyway the reason we're talking
about him is because he made a video
about us
and you know we don't [ __ ] when people
talk [ __ ]
play that horn
yes
wait are we even doing that anymore
i don't [ __ ] around when people talk
[ __ ]
but that's usually about weaker feet
no this is about going to war anything
for any purpose
you hear that
[Music]
[ __ ]
people don't [ __ ]
but this guy is such an easy this guy's
such a [ __ ] easy target because he's
such a douche
such a douche of course everything comes
down to this joe rogan clip funnily
enough like the uh
the
i don't know the whole
story has echoed through
because it's like joe rogan his daddy
he's like daddy conservative now
and and like he he's like anti-covet
anti-vaxx and all this [ __ ] like so the
conservatives prop them up like see
and of course uh
crowder got offended
that i said you should listen to the cdc
which as you know is an awful opinion
which is of course why like half a
million people died or like six hundred
thousand now how many people died now in
the u.s i think i cleared six hundred
thousand i oh it did i think
i love how he can be like dude this guy
says listen to the cdc what a tool cut
scene to
to uh someone dying on a ventilator it's
just under 600 yeah so here's what he
says about it and
i don't think i've ever seen it more i
have a i have a lot to say about crowder
to be honest with you guys
who by the way this guy was recently
[ __ ] his whole channel was
demonetized on youtube for being such a
[ __ ] bag and that is hard to do you
basically have to be like isis to get
demonetized by youtube
i was saying you know
the only two channels i know that were
outright banned is
leafy is here and isis
so he wasn't even banned he was
permanently demonetized indefinitely in
death which means it could be lifted
because i guess it happened once before
and he was demonetized for about a year
and then oh for real and they gave it
back well this has happened already to
him this is round two
what was he demonetized for the first
time
uh it was for
harassing this journalist who's gay oh
um right i remember that yeah
he right right it was a whole thing and
youtube really played it poorly too if
you recall because they like
they picked everyone off they
flip-flopped like 10 times on it and
managed to make everybody upset in the
process it was very dumb of them
i do remember well anyway in this most
recent one he um his first strike was
for
spreading election misinformation
obviously nevada voters mysterious the
nevada voter mystery deepens
he claimed that an unknown person or
group altered public records to hide the
fact
of a former hillary aide
who has been missing for two years may
have voted illegally
anyway he got a strike for that one
he got a second strike
for an episode covering the killing of a
16 year old boy
by police crowder and his co-host argued
that the shooting was justified making
jokes about the circumstance of the
shooting
that's pretty cool and then i you guys
may recall the day that the george floyd
verdict came out he made he literally
posted a mock
george floyd killing where one of his
homies kneeled on his neck
so i mean the guy's a piece of [ __ ]
let's be honest
anyway let's see what he says
i believe it was the day he came back to
youtube after oh that's right
he got
suspended correct for
i think it was because of that first
strike i think it was the nevada thing
i mean i thought
it could be wrong it's hard to keep
track because
i don't get these guys they act so
shocked when [ __ ] happens it's like
you've been testing the boundaries
relentlessly well it's
it's
it's a feature not a bug you know what i
mean like
every time they get in trouble with
youtube they get more support from their
audience for sure yeah i know i know it
was a part of the grift i believe it was
about the uh black farmers when he was
making the joke oh dude and then that
one he go he goes right yeah i can't
even show it it's so racist he goes
there's no he's like the subsidies to
there's a was a specific carve out and
the
uh one of the bills for covid relief for
black farmers and he's like there's no
such thing as a black farmer and he was
making all these crazy stereotypes about
like the farmers like waiting for
jordans and
spending the money on jordans instead of
farm equipment and [ __ ] real low-hanging
crazy like super racist [ __ ] bro
it's crazy that you can be like that
much of a [ __ ] bag and have and people
are like yeah that's what they like
anyway here's what he says
okay here's something that i really
wanted to touch on this guy uh i think
his name what's his what's his i can't
like there's so much to say because i
haven't really talked about him but the
dude has such small dick energy that
he's wearing a holster he wears a
[ __ ] gun holster bro oh my god like
he's such a he has such big energy he
needs a gun holster to feel like magic
he's wearing it as like an accessory
yeah yeah yeah always yes
he wears a gun holes here bro
and he's got tissues next to him in case
you know
he starts crying
exactly
in case he starts crying and his mascara
starts running or if he you
know and i was going to make a jizz in
his pants joke but i don't know where
that's going you're it was just funnier
frankly but why is there i mean dude
having fun on the desk that big of a
necessity pro tip for all guys don't
wear this kind of shirt too good call
bad luck baseball tees yeah
well anytime you put a a a
holster over it yeah which i guarantee
is empty
because let's be honest his homies don't
want to show up to the office with when
this dude is off un
unhinged with guns on his side
but yeah
uh token allen is it is his real name
ethan
ethan ethan
it the htc yeah it's ethan
what is it there
okay
look at this big show he's trying to act
like he doesn't know i am crowder has
been such a [ __ ] he's been trying to
collab and get me on his show and come
on hitting my show and i'm always like i
don't [ __ ] like this guy he's a
massive douchebag and i've always
ghosted him
him and ben shapiro and dave rubin and
all those guys always wanted to hook up
with me because i was making social
justice warrior videos what's his name
ethan ethan ethan what's the name
i've never heard that name ethan yeah
it's like you know who i am i don't know
how to pronounce this
and if you don't know who i am you
definitely have heard of the name ethan
before
is it ethon ethan ethan ayton
so
i have an email by the way from his like
producer assumption one of his producers
trying to get me to come on the show
here i'll read it because there's some
funny excerpts in it
louder with crowder
here let's see
i thought i started oh here it is i'm in
the wrong email
he sent it to my business you know
because he didn't have my [ __ ] normal
email
thank you jack i needed that
i thought it'd be you know you have this
you have this star feature if it doesn't
put it at the top of your pile it's like
what am i gonna go here it is anyway so
hi i'm a celebrity talent booker
for louder with crowder i'd love to book
ethan cline
ethan ethan klein old they even bolded
my name that his real name what they
bolded my name
they said louder with crowder
is a
syndicated show
uh hosted by steven crowder stand up
comedian
he may be many things but i don't think
this [ __ ] is a stand-up comedian
he was a post for four years on fox news
he was their youngest ever contributor
it said roger ailes even had around with
him
[Laughter]
steven's irreverent edgy yet
distinctively conservative style has
thrust him
into the national success appearing on
most major cable shows
and then when i didn't respond
this booker was so desperate to get me
she said she responded let's see
five days later good morning following
up on the below request can we find a
day that works and then again seven days
later forwarded me at the original email
again
so crowder is very desperate to get me
on his show for a guy who says he who
was never he does he he doesn't he knows
me so little he doesn't even know how to
pronounce ethan
he's never even heard of that name
before
choder ethan klein your mic's on there
yeah you're the audio guy ethan klein
i love how the the sub audio guy has to
be an angle that i really wanted to
touch on oh boy this guy uh i think his
name what's his what's his name there uh
uh token allen is it is his real name
ethan ethan i can't believe he's wearing
the uh
you're the audio guy but i don't see
them laughing i know i love how the sub
audio guy has no i'm saying podcasts
right when they're singing look anyone
can do a podcast
right so this is h3h3 is like a popular
podcast on youtube
and um
this is kind of when people criticize
podcasts right when they're saying look
anyone can do a podcast super used to be
with radio or television
yeah and i understand that but i also
have a problem with gatekeepers because
sometimes we're interesting people who
couldn't make it through the gatekeepers
because they were too controversial
right but then there were some people
who have no business really being on air
because they don't offer anything so
this
exhibit here of h3h reproductions
is is perfect it's like you know this
when you've done stand-up right and then
every stand-up community is like i do a
podcast people like oh yeah my husband's
unemployed too yes of course
there's over one million people right i
know that that doesn't surprise me dude
this is like
so funny that there's so many people
with podcasts but not many of them are
good right that's an observation that is
super unique yeah new right right
i heard even are you hurt yeah it did
okay it hurt a lot
you know what did you call him
stephen
even trump knows how to say my name
stephen ethan stephen is his name stefan
they were uh upset
about joe rogan i guess something
something joe rogan talking about masks
i just think this is one of the most pop
one of the more popular podcasts on
youtube from what i understand
i don't think i've ever seen a more
perfect encapsulation she's calling our
podcast one of the more popular ones but
at the same time uh we have no uh no
business doing a podcast and he's never
heard of it yeah
he tried to get on it multiple times i
tried to get you on his show multiple
times it's a [ __ ] goon i i think it's
so funny when people pretend like they
don't know someone like bro come on
just say i know him i know about him i
don't like him
it's fine
of group think
and discouraging any sort of critical
thinking whatsoever and laughing about
it with no self-awareness this is my
favorite clip uh of the year let's roll
this guy wants to talk about
self-awareness while he's sitting there
with that
and a box of tissue next to him
bro why do you have a box of tissue look
how much do you need tissue how much
tissue does he use in a shell
like i have this tissue in my house like
in the bathroom
but you're on set you're recording
you're not gonna need a gun there's a
tissue next to that what's with the
holster
unless he's really just wearing it as an
accessory which is also pretty bad now
it's part of the grift it's like i'm one
of you i'm a badass all right
i'm a i'm a la based comedian but i'm
not one of the coastal elites
high target that someone might burst in
trying to shoot him even during the show
i don't think he's in l.a walking target
just uh just to correct you on that i
think he lives in texas or some [ __ ] of
course
i feel like he's like a where is he from
i'll fact-check it but i don't think he
does his show from los angeles
all right
anyway this is his favorite clip of the
year i'm glad he enjoyed it maybe
there's a reason it's one of the most
popular podcasts right i mean even if we
can dissatisfy you this much
yeah uh he's based in dallas
oh
oh boy oh why'd i have to say it
out here in texas
we coming up now boys
[Applause]
yeah oh my god is he really yeah he's
canadian we need to
we need to stop letting them in we need
to stop letting him in
i'm saying he's born in detroit oh oh a
b
detroit but people say that he's
canadian all the time yeah what the [ __ ]
citizenship yeah is from canada his uh
wikipedia says he's an american canadian
conservative political commentator so i
don't know
all i know
is that i once i'm done shooting my gum
i'm gonna wipe the tears away because
boy is that scary ethan
ethan
ethan
all right let's watch let's watch let's
watch
and you gotta wear a mask so i'm out
there wearing a mask wow big deal and
then now they say you know if you're
outside you don't need to wear a mask
it's pretty simple you want to talk
about it
yeah i mean there's a whole there's a
whole the cdc is like this whole
governmental body with scientists and
[ __ ] they just tell us what to do you
don't have to think about it dude
okay now first of all he shows like he's
made this whole declaration that we have
no business doing podcasts this is all
he watches in this it's like five
seconds
obviously my point is that if you're so
[ __ ] stupid
then yeah you should listen to the cdc
bro it's there
like
i don't understand this assumption that
he like
rednecks understand more than then
doctors have spent their whole life
studying ep like disease man he's
googled he's googled around for 10
minutes dude yeah he's not anti-vaxxy
he's just asking questions
i'm getting ahead of myself let me play
it
you think that was
rehearsed he's definitely watched it
after dark
seriously they're just telling you don't
have to think about it dude by the way
my my rule is right whatever we say
always just extend the context a minute
in either direction it only gets worse
but he says that but he didn't show
anything else we talked about
i don't know it doesn't no i watched it
he does it
because i was like i hope he does show
the context because he gets like all the
basis of facts wrong
but listen but like i was like dude you
could have at least showed more of the
cliff honestly
i'm so stupid why is he questioning uh
any like the cdc or fouchy yeah
seriously bro you're not a doctor i
don't even know i don't want to think
about things bro do you [ __ ] question
like let's say the the the uh
god is so dumb
it's like so
do you go to the doctor and then he
i literally can't do you go to the
pharmacy and overlook their and you'll
be like oh is that the right medicine
you know what i'm saying like yeah
there's certain people in this world
that we don't need to [ __ ] that we
especially when you're such a dumb ass
and you don't understand how disease
prevention works then you should be
listening to dr fauci and the and the
cdc also i mean
it makes sense too so i choose to listen
to it you know it's logical they're not
telling me um go jump off a building and
i'm like well this doesn't make sense
but i'll do it anyway
they're saying wear a mask during a
pandemic pretty with a disease that
spreads
that spreads through the air like it's
so it's pretty easy it's kind of logical
yeah so i kind of don't have a problem
listening to people who know what
they're talking about when they also are
making sense yeah it also makes sense
people who are vaccinated and people who
wear masks if you look at like
taiwan and new zealand are like you know
asian countries where mask wearing is is
uh prevalent there's no [ __ ] disease
bro everything makes sense so you don't
need to question every single [ __ ]
thing that comes up in your life dude i
think that's part of your problems
but we're just when you look at
ingredients on your food do you go to
the packing uh
plant and and then re-examine everything
he probably grows only his own food
why is this homie dressed up as peter
pan too
his homies dressed as peter pan there's
a tissue on the table he's got a gun
which you know is a youth which is just
like a metaphor for [ __ ]
these guys fought it's got to be some
sort of inside joke maybe they're
shifting maybe they're shifting oh maybe
they're drifting
there's definitely shifting crowder
wants to be the little uh
never boys what are they called the lost
yeah he's a lost boy for sure
what people tell me and we just went
through without you how he went from it
occurred in nature oh no it may have
happened in a lab they've been wrong so
you could if you do that there are many
instances where you could have made
yourself very sick well yeah when do
what from what from wearing a mask i'm
wearing a mask yeah
oh what are you doing i have so much
regret that i wore yeah oh my god i
worry i'm mad i can't believe i wore a
master in that pandemic oh that was so
[ __ ] stupid of me i should never
listen to these scientists that spent
their whole life studying this
i got to think for myself
um i get all my information from
facebook groups
free thinkers
i don't know they always do that they
always try to undermine uh fauci's uh
his whole credibility because in the
beginning he said don't you don't need
to wear a mask and then he said you do
need to wear a mask and like he changed
his mind based on
the situation right and they act like
you can never change your [ __ ] mind
on anything otherwise it proves that
you're lying and that you should never
listen to them he's like listen to it
listen to dr fauci bro
yes especially you dumbass
ethan oh thank you trump can you say
that
what was that ethan what's that word
what does that word mean
ethan never heard that
even how to read the name bro you think
that tissue's made of paper
you just trust what the what the tissue
people tell you ethan you trust that
coffee you're drinking you just trust
sheep
you could be making decisions that could
impact your health forever by trusting
that that's coffee
i don't trust that's coffee unless like
that could what could be in that coffee
you don't know ethan
by the way i think it's a beautiful
thing
when um
science
will change something they'll be like
hey we know we know now that something
is different than we knew before yeah
it's a beautiful thing because they have
data and they learn
right
it's a great thing
right no but if you ever change your
mind that's the one thing that's proof
that there's a conspiracy and that
they're idiots and that you need to
think for yourself
do i follow them at what point along the
chain of their changing their own way
every time the way i should go every
single time you should always follow
their advice
from before and after they change their
opinion
and not from a facebook group that tells
you that bill gates is putting a
microchip in your shoulder
well no sorry that's the way i share you
didn't understand his last half you
don't even have to think about it dude
exactly it's that simple
they're scientists that spent their
whole [ __ ] life bro imagine you
couldn't you wouldn't even have to make
this video if you just didn't even think
about it when people smarter than you
that dedicated their whole life to
scientific research you look at all the
stress and strain on him that could have
been
prevented don't even have to think about
it
i agree
they're just they like to think a lot
i'm trying to think but nothing happens
exactly when you think and nothing
happens then you should listen to the
cdc that's my point
i was watching
hassan reacted uh to this clip and he
said
he used he doesn't see crowder usually
get this worked up so he was impressed
that i got him so triggered so i thought
that was kind of fun well
somebody pointed out and we didn't
realize it when we were talking about it
last night that um
i believe it was the same episode that
you first mentioned what you just went
into the fact that crowder had tried to
get you on the show right so i have a
suspicion that that is what this is
really about
he's butt hurt that i ghosted him
out of them
exactly
come on bro
trying to think but nothing happens
you're already too far
out of
the prison that he said they tell you
what to do you don't even have to think
about it dude
look that's not a good rule of thumb for
anything in life
but they act like man it's a gold rule i
mean yeah when you're as dumb as you
that can't understand [ __ ] and you're
like literally becoming a biohazard
you should listen to cdc bro
i know that
i mean what's the point of government if
we don't trust these whole institutions
that we've propped up funded
regulated but you don't
the whole society breaks down you don't
have to blindly follow it even i mean
yeah you can say critically about it but
like
about a mask it makes sense this is very
straightforward this is we're not
talking about like oh going and getting
a second um
second opinion from a second doctor
chopping up your leg bro right have a
big surgery to do fine of course if the
advice was extreme and seeing talking
about your eyebrow raising yeah i mean
it's just it is common sense it's just
common sense
i don't think these guys should think
and i stand by that
the less they think the better off we
all are that's true that's true
i really truly believe that
you know
like
there's so much governmental bodies that
tell us what to do that we don't think
about
and they don't walk around with holsters
food
you know i trust all the science and
[ __ ] that goes on
does steven wear a seatbelt when he
drives a car does he
have steep belts for [ __ ] he probably
doesn't
he's got he's got a giant [ __ ]
his holster has a little clip-on there
you go he just everyone in here is the
idiot
i didn't say that but yeah people that
watch this podcast is it like does it
have i think it's relative yeah it's
popular seriously here's how it gets i
just i wanted to be on it ethan
[Laughter]
it's so i think it's popular i did
invite him three times i begged him to
come on my show
i love how the dude and the big green
polo is saying does he want to watch
this he's the one trying to back off
yeah [ __ ] peter pan ass looking
[ __ ]
maybe tell me you touch kids without
telling me you touch kids
[Laughter]
his homie here maybe it's a halloween
party he's peter pan uh crowder is uh
indiana jones
with the oh you think they're right
there yeah i seem to recall seeing him
in that outfit before i think maybe
that's just his thing on the show yeah
he hangs out at schools after work he's
shifting dan come on yeah he's shifting
right he's a shifter he's a shifter
he's shifting to a world where it's
acceptable to hang out with young boys
all day
i think it's relative yeah it's popular
here's how i guarantee you something if
there's a guy in a man and a woman i
should say on one side of the desk and
the woman is in a sideways hat uh
everything they're saying is useless
sideways hats
we were wearing the [ __ ] bass pro
shop hats oh
because i went back i was like wait what
is he talking about because i have to go
back so because here you're wearing the
bath pro shop
but like
this guy's a comedian this guy's like oh
my god
that's your rule bro that's a rule
here's here's a rule anytime you're in a
room with a dude dressed like peter pan
and a dude with an animal
then you're either you're either
you're either [ __ ] dude to be fair we
were wearing it ironically of course
that's why they missed the content of
literally everything and they continue
yeah what happened was jorgen said why
is this girl
but they act like everyone in here is
the idiot yeah are there any people that
watch this podcast is it like yes
i think it's relative yeah it's popular
seriously here's how i guarantee you
something if there's a guy in a man and
a woman i should say on one side of the
desk and the woman is in a sideways hat
uh everything they're saying is useless
he does not he doesn't talk like he's
thought about anything in life well
that's funny that you just because she
went after joe rogan because apparently
i think he made fun of her hat or her
mask are you serious yeah what happened
was jorgen said why is this girl uh
she's outside and she's wearing a double
mask she's like yeah i was working i
love what it turns into double mask like
the battle just changed yeah the fact is
it was at whitney cummings party she was
wearing one mask this was at the height
of the pandemic when gathering was like
basically illegal i think everyone in
l.a everyone got tested fine but still i
chose to wear a mask that's what you're
supposed to do yeah
your mask you just listen to the cdc
you sheep you just listen to scientists
a whole governmental body that spent its
entire is full of people dedicated to
learning about disease prevention and
viruses
yeah you presume to know more than them
well you know yeah run the double mask
because where did he get the double mask
exactly he's just exaggerating because
at least immediately he says if you
watch if you watch it oh right
these guys are so mental bro that's uh
tucker saying if you see a kid wearing a
mask call the poli child
abuse
um
man
yeah it turns into double he says if you
watch it a minute before after it's even
worse i was like then show it [ __ ] he
doesn't logan because apparently i think
he made fun of her hat or her mask oh
something are you serious yeah what
happened was jorgen said why is this
girl uh she's outside and she's wearing
a double mask she's like yeah i was
wearing the double mask because at that
time the cdc was saying even if you're
fascinated you have to wear a double
mask so i wore a double mask nope didn't
say any of that the cdc never even said
no there was no vaccine no the vaccine
didn't exist when that incident happened
no i know i'm just saying
every single detail yeah exactly
yeah he misses every single detail what
happened was jorgen said why is this
girl uh she's outside and she's wearing
a double mask he's like yeah i was
wearing the double mask because at that
time the cdc was saying even if you're
faster than me he literally you know
this was his favorite clip this was his
favorite clip of the entire year and
yeah he didn't even watch it
[ __ ] awesome
you're gonna need one of those tissues
that may have been from a bit or
something the tissue well just
bro he said the thing about the hat i
don't want to make the same mistake you
know what i mean
[Music]
super high level thinking well at least
i'm watching the part that's relevant to
what true he's i watched the whole
segment about it right that's not true
dan i'm watching the whole [ __ ]
segment if his homie happens to be
dressed as peter pan and he's got jerk
off tissues on the clip that's fair game
for me right because i'm watching the
whole damn thing fair enough thank you
get me fired up here
think about it dude i wear double hat
both sides imagine look imagine if who
who is
my accent yeah for sure wow
why does this guy even have
like this guy's supposed to be a
comedian
you're not enemy number one you're like
you're foreign and you're a woman yeah
right exactly
and you're outspoken and you have a
sideways hat right right i made it to
america
his ass is canadians what the [ __ ] he
sucking his ass was foreign
yeah right
i saw a lot of comments uh earlier from
our canadian fans saying we do not claim
him so we want him i don't want them
yeah we don't
well [ __ ] i don't know what to do with
them texas is like yeah that's our boy
powder no i love uh
every canadian person that i met so i
don't i don't hold it against you guys
except him
yeah accept it that was applied uh
any i mean that's exactly mao is china
yeah dude this is when he goes like so
off the rails
i'm not even following his logic how is
china he goes from ila wearing a mask
a double mask while she's vaccinated
right which none of that is true
but he goes to either wearing a mask
during a pandemic with the airborne
virus
and listening to the cdc to maoist china
ussr i mean but that is what that's what
in other words the government would come
in and try and recondition you that's
exactly what this is
you may hear things that speak out
against government but you are not to
listen to them hey listen i don't even
want to think about it dude
what is he hi
i mean
it always comes down to
your communist for wanting to wear a
mask okay he's saying that
he's using the cdc of what are you
saying like your your mentality of
listening to the government
is is
what happens in a totalitarian
communist state i was just saying that
it's a bit of a stretch to say it's
aware of math bro yeah
during during a pandemic and with an
airborne virus yeah what the [ __ ] again
it does
how many people were dying a day at the
peak during around that time it was like
it was like
ten thousand people would destroy
something yeah i mean a lot [ __ ]
crazy bro
it's like
i don't know if you guys have seen the
data but like in for example southern
california and new york and stuff like
that where people are
getting the vaccine a lot
the kovid numbers are like dropping to
almost nothing but if you go to parts of
the community where people are hesitant
and not getting the vaccine covet is
is spiking in those communities people
are getting sick the virus is still
spreading and in l.a it's like gone
there's like no [ __ ] virus here
anymore guess why because vaccines work
wow
it was the same thing of masks too i
mean the data was just so obvious
but somehow that's me
uh that's maoist china by the way we've
experienced it ourselves we've been
around people that had it and while we
were wearing a mask we didn't catch it
so right had some close calls it's like
i'm i i i
i do follow the guidelines but it also
makes sense
that's the body and you had yeah and you
had if you have half a brain well that's
why you're even saying that because it's
like when did the cdc ask anybody to
like chop off an arm to prevent you know
what i'm saying like they're not asking
you to do crazy [ __ ] they literally said
wear a mask and keep six feet apart from
people is that really filling into like
a little bit
yes it's so little to ask stephen
it's not maoist china bro
we don't need slight presentation i'm
not from russia
well he i guess he's he's trying to do
that
yeah russia russians are communists
vladimir putin
i don't know if he was making don't let
him hear you say vladimir putin he'll
know
vladimir putin
i've never heard of russia who's the
leader of russia
vladimir
perfect pronunciation exactly it's great
they just said don't think in so many
words yeah we including the words don't
and think this guy's joke don't hit
he doesn't hit he's never i don't even
understand
you don't say
okay well listen we're going to take
your crops now and uh good luck with the
weight loss okay
listen
what
it's just wearing a mask bro it's not
stealing your crops
you know
no you want to think you don't even have
to think about it dude and they're the
guys also last i checked like i mean
american democracy has like in terms i
mean we're not in russia doug why are
you so skeptical about this country he's
apparently this great patriot but he's
so skeptical he's like of the
institution of his own country that he's
comparing the cdc to [ __ ]
russians
stealing food from peasants yeah you
know when
this party happened and eli was
following the guidelines and everything
uh donald trump was president and this
was his administration's advice that he
was following like this is his guy
right
you know it's not impossible it's not
communism dude
donald trump's vaccinated
you got that real quick you got those
stem cell babies shot right into his
[ __ ] eyeballs
you know what i mean donald trump knows
kovitz real
people you know those people were let's
say you make a self-deprecating joke yes
and then you say something like i meant
to do that and then there's that girl i
think she's really clever she's like
yeah right like no he didn't it's like
oh you caught something this is what
that is like you don't even have to
think about it what is this analogy i
literally i'm not [ __ ] following him
he's getting this like he's getting so
worked up yeah and you can tell us homie
is not it's just nice and then you say
something like i meant to do that and
then there's that girl thing she's
really clever she's like yeah right oh
my goodness
oh you caught something this is what
that is like you don't have to think
about it dude people out there are
thinking
why
if a few people
[Laughter]
you know 25 speed
let's get nice and close oh no oh no
gets nice and juicy lips
lick
[Music]
anyway now listen to peter pan this this
one makes even less sense than
everything else they've been saying
a lot more european jews alive a lot
more russians alive a lot more
cambodians alive a lot more chinese
alive they've all been massacred because
people didn't think about it okay
why holocaust
just people didn't think about it
the reason the holocaust happened is
because people didn't think about it
dude
i can't even process who didn't think
about it the jews
people you're not following
you're not following what you're saying
the
whole pot cambodia millions of people
dead
people didn't think about it dude
what didn't they think about
i'm pretty sure there was plenty of
people thinking about how [ __ ] up it
was
and had no power to control their
destiny no
like imagine the jews on the train to
auschwitz is he trying to say like that
the nazi
soldiers were just following orders
that's the only logical explanation i
guess that okay that's a better
explanation than it it's the jew's fault
because they just didn't think about it
well it's like oh either all right i
guess i'll just get on this train i
won't think about it this is awesome
dude yeah right this rules
putting on i'm just going to dig this
ditch while my whole family starves to
death
this rules
russians alive a lot more cambodians
alive a lot more chinese alive they've
all been massacred because people didn't
think about it okay hey han let's do a
podcast where we people didn't think
let's listen to that
things that we don't think about you
know what this guy is he's like a
[ __ ] thrift store pat in
he looks just like him but he's just
dude not i see it it's just damn okay so
here's another hot take from
from dollar store pounds where we talk
about things that we don't think about
yeah
isn't that your podcast got him
you didn't think much about the clip you
didn't even watch it bro you know what
let's just let's just not think and
broadcast
what could go wrong hey
follow us on instagram by the way follow
me on instagram uh because uh look at
this [ __ ] dude he's such beta energy
with the [ __ ] cigar
the holster all these dudes the cigar
thing is just
the overcompensation it's real is this
guy trying to dress like marty mcfly or
is that actually an outfit he wears
like
you know that
he has to be trying because that is
actually that's literally mario
okay
dude he wears a cigar he's so alpha bro
so sick
it's so [ __ ] manly to just have a big
brown turd in your mouth all the time
dude and a holster
man
this guy thinks about everything
yeah we have a lot about to talk about
crowder though
yeah um
we have our caller who's been on hold
for a while we should um
should
charge forward into the uh the whole
lawsuit thing oh she's been on hold okay
i didn't know that emily is actually uh
emily baker who called him previously
she's our legal correspondent
um
because crowder is suing youtube
apparently for demonetizing him let's
see let me pull this up real quick he
claims he's suing both uh youtube and
facebook
um okay good luck yeah the the facebook
lawsuit was announced in february and
then he just announced uh a week or two
ago a lawsuit against youtube here he
says crowder llc
uh
through its lawyers gave a legal notice
to youtube of the intent to file a
lawsuit and sync an injunction here
let's watch this filed a notice of a
lawsuit
can get emily ready
and are seeking an injunction
uh to prevent them to stop them from
currently de-platforming us i want to be
really clear this is different from bro
you can so he can upload so the claim of
the platform is right i mean on
i think he was locked out of uploading
for a time but yeah
i think at the moment he can it's just
that if he gets another strike he'll be
completely banned from the platform and
so he's out of an abundance of caution
not uploading got it
that's a good idea i mean i've seen his
content
right i mean the one about me was
bordering on covet misinformation
kind like he was flirting with it sure
yeah
claims encounter claims or people
thinking that their content is being
throttled
we've officially sent a notice of a
lawsuit a
very different level this is the big one
boys and girls
uh nz's first off we were demonetized in
the new year uh then we had uh a hard
strike that didn't count as a heart
strike but was like a warning hard
strike right then we had an actual heart
strike and we just had a second hard
strike on our channel so we'll go
through what all those are the most
recent one is is absurd uh
admittedly it's not even a violation in
and of itself of any policy we'll tell
you exactly like bro all i did was do a
mock murdering of george floyd like and
why wouldn't youtube allow want that
from what do you think about all this
from what i could tell the the mock
murdering of george floyd uh wasn't one
of the strengths yeah which is you're
right i just think pretty surprising i
just think it's funny that he did that
emily what do you think about this one i
am merit
hey everybody good to see you guys again
i think that he well he hasn't filed a
lawsuit yet so we don't know exactly
what claims he's going to be bringing
against youtube he said notice of a
lawsuit and he also said these aren't
claims or counter claims i think they
sent a demand letter to youtube and are
asking or threatening that they're going
to file for an injunction to not further
demonetize his channel or not further
strike his channel but i found his
lawsuit against facebook filed by the
same attorney in the central district of
texas but there's no suit filed against
youtube there or google or alphabet so
nothing's been filed i think this is
just a demand letter when he says notice
of lawsuit so a demand letter is
typically hey
i think you did this you suck if you
don't do these things with me or
settle or resolve in this way then i'm
going to sue you and normally lawyers
will attach a copy of the lawsuit to
show that they're way [ __ ] serious
about it and just be like this is what
we're going to sue you with if you don't
work with us on what we're asking for so
i think we're at the demand letter stage
i don't think there's been a lawsuit
filed we haven't seen that what's the
purpose of a demand i mean it seems like
if you really want to sue someone you
would just sue them why [ __ ] and like
youtube is youtube's going to throw his
demand letter in the garbage probably
right
i mean i can't it depends on what he
says i can't imagine that they won't
youtube has tons of lawsuits going on at
any given time through you know google
and alphabet and currently has a lawsuit
going on about not enforcing their own
their own policies with regard to
malicious dcma takedowns which i think
is hilarious um or dmca i always get the
letters flipped but
youtube could work with him and say hey
we can explain our policy to you and
then you don't have to sue us if he's
looking for more transparency and for
him if he's looking to immediately not
get his channel taken down he might not
want to go through years of litigation
you guys know how long that can take to
actually get a resolution he might hope
that youtube will see the
uh i don't know the pressure that he's
trying to put on them by announcing this
and trying to rally the troops if you
will behind him and maybe work with him
because of that i don't know if they're
likely to acquiesce youtube's been
pretty stalwart in their policies
particularly their creator code of
conduct and they've banged david dobrik
over it and they've banged james charles
over it so if they're demonetizing him
because of creator code of conduct i
don't know what he's going to say about
that i mean yeah like legally
it's interesting because
it seems like he's saying that a private
company shouldn't be able to
to enforce their rule like what what
exactly i'm again there's no actual
complaint so we can only speculate but
it seems that his argument is like i
have the freedom i have free speech and
you are infringing on my free speech
and the thing that's interesting about
youtube is youtube still is a private
entity so we're going to see a lot of
these arguments over the coming years
pushed about whether youtube is actually
discriminating on its platform if they
are not really a private company if
they're more of a platform like a
utility or like a common carrier and
we're seeing people try to figure out
what youtube is really but youtube has
the right to not allow people on their
platform at this point and we see
actually both political parties trying
to figure out what to do with social
media in different ways to because they
are not liking different results with
social media being able to
silence people as they perceive it to be
but at the end of the day youtube has to
protect other creators and so i get
youtube's argument like look if you're
making the platform a mess and
advertisers don't want to advertise with
you like adpocalypse then it hurts
creators like y'all and like me and so
if one creator is causing a problems on
the platform or problems for the
platform
as creators is it something where we're
like yes all creators should have a
voice everyone should be able to say
whatever they want on youtube and i
don't care if advertisers don't want to
be on the platform anymore or
is it hey this company has to protect
what we're monetizing because others
have actually built their businesses
here too so youtube's in an interesting
position with that and i'm not sure
exactly what they demonetized him over i
know he's said some things that are
quite out out in a field um he's done
some things on his channel that are out
in the field i generally lean towards
letting people say what they want and
letting the audience decide if they
watch it or not but at the end of the
day youtube's a company and they do have
policies
i think you're right though we aren't
going towards interesting terrain
because it's like
it's like on the right they're super pro
business and against regulations so it's
like this is the result of that and then
i feel like it makes sense to regulate
tech companies because they're turning
into more
utility it's more of a utility let's be
honest then uh
you know and then there's also rules
like on facebook and youtube where
they're not publishers right they can't
be held
liable for what people post so there's
like all these uh
carve outs for them i feel yeah it's
gotten you're absolutely right ethan
it's gotten to a really interesting
place where because of
section 230 the platforms can't be sued
so
there's this protection that they have
and people are trying to get around that
protection and trying to figure out how
they can sue platforms because if you
want to free market it it's like okay
youtube's a private business do what you
want and then if you screw somebody over
they can sue you and say you're
discriminating against me but right now
with some of their protections they it's
not as easy to do that probably pulling
into this letter of demand saying hey
we're going to seek an injunction not
claims against you but an injunction to
stop you from doing this to me
and which just seems to be what crowder
is seeking in his you know notice of
lawsuit to them
but
with that 230 protection the right it's
really strange to me because they're
very pro-business and less regulation
but want to more heavily regulate what
social media can do so there's this
weird flipping of general ideology which
never sits well with me i'm like if your
ideology has let people do it then let
people do it and sometimes you don't
like the results it's it's just ironic
because on the left people who have
always been trying to regulate uh social
medias to agree and then all of a sudden
it's like yeah we've been saying that
for years but all of a sudden ironically
now you want to now you want to regulate
what they can do interesting
it's very interesting and i
i think you're right sorry i totally cut
you off no it's just it's ironic that
all of a sudden when it's not going for
him he wants to regulate them and it's a
huge liberal conspiracy and not just him
being a douchebag but hey that's just
one guy's opinion
i think we're going to see some
interesting things happen with how
government treats social media because
there is this is there room for
discrimination on platforms can they say
hey we don't like what you say how you
say it who you are saying it and is that
a problem for all creators and i think
so um we want to have all kinds of
voices we don't want to live in an echo
chamber and if people say horrible stuff
then they generally get held accountable
for that um with regards to audience but
youtube at the end of the day is going
to try to keep the platform friendly to
advertising and we've got to keep that
goal in mind so
if a content creator like crowder is
going to just put you know brand deals
on his content does he really need to be
monetized i you can still run brand
deals if you can still upload videos
yeah definitely
and i'm sure there's a mypillow ad
waiting for him oh god my pillow money's
crazy yeah or some gut and gun holster
company or something
[Laughter]
maybe that's what's with the holster how
are you okay integration you've been
good
we're good i mean we've we've had an
interesting week my parents are in town
my my son broke his shoulder so you know
parent life how are you guys doing good
good good our son fell out of his crib
he didn't break his children
he just came along look
boy life
both of my kids have broken their arms
twice so i'm hoping that we're at the
end of it but
they if you let them do stuff sometimes
they fall yeah
sure well emily thank you for calling in
as usual we value your perspective
yeah emily d baker on youtube everywhere
emily d baker everywhere yep great to
see you both thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so to paraphrase crowder's a giant d-bag
oh should we go over all this other
stuff because we have like a whole
[ __ ] dossier on this idiot
uh yeah i don't know
we had kind of been toying with this
idea and i gotta say
i'm seeing a lot
of comments in the chat
i'm seeing a lot of favorite requests
if you could if you could pick one of
these to watch which one should i watch
or should i
uh
of of the cringe um
you know what's funny
the one where he has the quartering on
is pretty funny just because it's
hilarious that he thinks the quartering
is somebody worth having on his
[ __ ] corridor
but i don't know maybe we should save it
maybe we should save it
i just peed in my basement just ripped a
fat one did you yeah that was [ __ ]
super loud holy [ __ ]
i get really good because theodore loves
it
oh well if you do it for yourself so
[ __ ] amused when i fart loud like the
best part of his day yeah i'm excited to
sound about it and then he goes more
like i could fart on command that's
pretty cute
oh stinky i'm sorry
we've been talking we've been talking
about crowder for long enough yeah yeah
okay we'll do a crowder content card
that'd be fun uh i'll just this is this
is uh not gonna make sense to a lot of
people but just because i feel like
there's a decent chance steven crowder
will see this and this will be the only
time that i get to say this debate sam
cedar dude stop being such a [ __ ]
i know that your dad doesn't want you to
uh and
you know but that was a long time ago
that was three you're you're three years
older now it's time it's time to debate
sam
so do you want to give some context to
that dan he uh
there's a political uh uh youtube
channel called the majority report and
the host sam cedar uh
is one of those
like like stephen crowder he's a guy who
likes to debate and
they had scheduled a debate
at a big political convention uh called
politicon
uh that they you know it was all like
arranged and it was settled and
everything and um
sam got a call which he recorded and
played on his show which is what makes
it so good so we can validate this story
um where they explained that steven had
backed out and had gotten cold feet
which earned him a nickname cold feet
crowder
go to any of his tweets on twitter is
just to this day it's full of that uh
and um
and uh yeah and then they revealed that
it was that his like handler his agent
is basically his dad and his dad called
them and was like
he can't do it so why did he why
probably because he knew he was good
because sam cedar isn't yeah he's not a
[ __ ] 19 year old college student he
actually knows what he's talking about
yeah he was going to get embarrassed and
um his daddy said no yeah his dad said
no he's daddy's looking out for him so
um daddy do you like my holster
does it make me look big and tough so i
don't know i never thought i would get
the opportunity to send a message
directly to crowder and so i'm using
this opportunity to say
daddy debate sam cedar please [ __ ]
owned good [ __ ] dan he's going to get
two more holsters on his legs now
daddy
daddy do you like my holsters i'm going
to get a new holster that you like so i
can look masculine and you'll be proud
of me
daddy is it okay if i invite ethan on my
show
daddy he had the he had to put that
invitation through with daddy first
daddy daddy
anyway that's about it
you guys are all these guys are all
grifters though so easy to be a
conservative on youtube you just say
like the most obvious [ __ ]
black people deserve to be
black people are violent criminals
there's no such thing as systemic racism
well it's not that easy apparently
this channel might get determinated
right it's risky business but they love
that too they get to be the victims
of it isn't real
dr fauci eats babies apparently every
victory
i should do man i should start like a
cold bear report i miss that show
or i just do like a i should make a
character that's just a fake
conservative
do we like that we hate that oh this i
mean i i loved the colbert report back
in the day um i don't know
i don't know if that works in this i
think youtube will ban me immediately
the thing is is that it's all predicated
on satire and satire is just it's kind
of just a dead art form in the world we
live in i'll be getting exposed every
day ethan clyne says
dr fauci eats babies
we got what we got what we got what we
got i texted the doctor
[Laughter]
do we have confirmation read it read it
verbatim
i texted her i said
i did the blast test today and waiting
to hear the results do you know if it's
ready and she said
3.92 i have no idea what that number
means but she was like
exclamation mark you are super pregnant
i told you i knew it
yes
oh
wow oh my god
amazing it worked
super pregnant
not just pregnant super pregnant
shredder come here mommy's super
pregnant
i knew it
when i put that load
sorry
[Music]
oh what do we got here oh
what are you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's let's [ __ ] kill that
baby
jesus
oh what we got some fancy [ __ ] yeah it's
a good champagne i got you we were
supposed to do a toast for the new
office too
i'm so excited congratulations guys
that's so amazing
we just got the news yeah i thought i
might as well try to text her because i
know the show is like about to end
well i wasn't sure if she went out there
that was the original title
i
oh that's so great you know it was
getting so frustrated cheers by the way
cheers guys
and cheers everyone in the chat thank
you guys thank you everyone for all the
really nice
[Music]
that's crazy
it worked
you know um
we're trying and trying and the few the
fertility stuff is so brutal i'm
stabbing her in the stomach injecting
her oh my god i hate it so much it's
kind of awesome though because you they
made you have your period early because
we went to
vegas and it worked
not period though obviously
yeah yeah
they give you like a trigger shot and
then it and then you ovulate i don't
know now we have to see if you have
twins or triplets
wait so is this a vegas baby
no no no no it was before vegas okay but
it was right before like we left the
next day
no they yeah it was at the doctor's
office right right right
well we did it the night before so it
could have been that one too i felt good
about that one too
or like you guys before right so i was i
was having a good feeling about that one
as well
you know
because i was
i'm going to take the whole credit i'm
trying to take off
exercising and i was like i feel
powerful oh and you know what me too i i
actually started to like
eat um
better and um
i'm trying to make sure that i eat a lot
of protein because i'm not a meat person
so i'm like i gotta eat beans and
lentils and mexican things like this
that's the one we can discuss
it sounds like you're describing mexican
so i feel like i've been taking good
care of myself too
that's so amazing that's such great news
we did it i'm so real i'm so relieved
and happy that it worked
because you always get like oh is this
gonna happen nothing's gonna happen we
tried it the first time it didn't work
this time it worked
wow
she's got a good job she gets to give
people good news all the time or bad
news i guess sometimes but
how bad i mean okay let's not go there
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
well where do you go from there i guess
that's the show right theodore's gonna
be a big brother now
yeah and shredder it's on theater's
birthday that we he's gonna find out
he's a big bro
oh that's cute
so that means the baby will be born in
march right i was doing the math the
other day that's it
yeah
because it's um
it's what is it it's may almost june
june july august september
october november december
january
february oh so like february i guess
february march
it's not also
it's weird but like by the time you're
pregnant it's already like the first
time
right it's already like the first month
right
by the time you find out so it's not
really nine more you're right so it's
then
it's in
february
or january february
january baby
a winter baby
winter is coming baby
oh a valentine's baby valentine's baby
oh love has
cut to me
love
cheers buddy cheers cheers guys cheers
congratulations thank you love you
oh that's so exciting
oh my god that's crazy you did it
you're the best that's so crazy you did
it dude
you got a baby in you you're super
pregnant
so then we gotta find out the gender if
there's a bunch of them
oh god
it's so crazy
well i gotta call my mom
right
yeah we gotta make some calls and stuff
now all right
not just pregnant you're super pregnant
so why is that stick not plain us dirty
if you're so pregnant yeah
whatever it does i i hate all those
tests i hate it so when you guys were
saying it earlier i mean i don't know
it's the hive mind of the chat but when
you said that you had a faint thing yeah
the chat was going crazy everybody was
saying that's pregnant that's what i
thought i was like that's pregnant i
don't know because it doesn't just show
up it doesn't just show up
because last time last time when we were
when we did the test and the first
pregnancy it was just positive you know
it wasn't like a faint line i thought
you had faint the day before and then we
took it in the morning and it was
positive
yes but this time it was still faint
yeah you did like four faints yeah but i
was like that means you're pregnant
you're definitely pregnant
oh that's great that's crazy
amazing
let's [ __ ] go
all right
the family is increasing watch out world
why are you holding your stomach oh well
i'll tell you guys i am not family
i'm already nine months pregnant
yo and i'll tell you guys right now i am
starting next week training five days a
week
i'm sorry not wake up in the morning
you're going for it monday through
friday training i'm sick of this [ __ ]
and i refuse to get gain even more
weight baby because when you're pregnant
i know i'm going to eat with you and
it's going to be awesome and i need i
want that in my life so i'm just going
to exercise a lot and i'm going to eat
like a monster with you my love
and also not and also i'm going to lose
weight at the same time
that's great man that's good energy
money baby we love that for you
i might have to leave my money trainer
though because he's not available in the
morning
dude
that's not money i i like nobody at all
it's not it's not money but i can't
[ __ ] you know what i mean i got to do
what i got to do there's not very cash
money of him i'll i'll tell my next
trainer to tell me money when i'm doing
good
all right you ready for the nine months
build up
yes
i'm ready the nine month build up was
nice i felt or the i guess the very end
got the very end is really difficult but
the good news is when you give birth
it's going to be easier this time it
will be easier yeah
it's like a five-hour ordeal last time
it was like 48 hours or 24 hours
you mean from contractions too and yeah
you like show up and you just give birth
apparently mm-hmm it's crazy that's what
they said i was like great that's
something awesome
yeah the first time was really a very
intense experience
they weren't they really want us to
culturation do you want to do that on
air or not
call trisha to tell them the news
should i call i mean no one no we want
to yeah yeah
more privately
we're actually having the family over oh
yeah everybody's coming over this
weekend for theodore's birthday
baby
we can tell them we're gonna do on the
weekend
and then we're having another party for
his birthday next weekend and in between
we're going to disneyland is going to be
[ __ ] all
have a good weekend see you next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're watching h233
you're watching h233
you're watching
h23 ammo
[Music]
you